Das Chaos Radio, eine Sendung über technische Systeme, die nicht immer so funktionieren, wie sie sollen, ist dieses Mal Opfer eines technischen Systems geworden, das nicht so funktioniert hat, wie es soll. Falls euer Ohr also an ein paar Aussetzern oder unvollständigen Sätzen hängen bleibt, bitten wir vielmals um Entschuldigung. Nächstes Mal wird es bestimmt wieder besser. Oder wir entdecken dann einen anderen spannenden Fehler. Jetzt aber viel Spaß beim Chaos Radio 266. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 266, wo wir uns damit beschäftigen, warum euer Gesicht und seine Datenrepräsentation auch in Zukunft euch gehören soll. Wir sprechen heute über Reclaim the Face, beziehungsweise Gesichtserkennung stoppen, eine Initiative eben genau dafür, um Gesichtserkennung zu stoppen. Und was dahintersteckt, was Biometrie dazu mit zu tun hat, was man jetzt gerade politisch dagegen tut und wie das alles zusammenhängt, dafür habe ich heute sehr viele Gäste da und begrüße recht herzlich in der Reihenfolge, wie sie im Patch stehen. Du bist beim Forum Informatikerinnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung und machst ansonsten noch was?
Ich bin wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter am Weizenbaum Institut für die Vernetzte Gesellschaft. Und da bin ich quasi Informatiker, der sich zu den Sozialwissenschaften neigt und die Hand reicht mit der sehr schönen Erfahrung, dass das auf der anderen Seite genauso ist, wenn man das so sagen möchte.
Okay, dann Dr. Andrea Knaut von der Gesellschaft für Informatik und auch vom FIF. Und du machst noch was?
Ich arbeite zurzeit in der Geschäftschelle für den dritten Gleichstellungsbericht der Bundesregierung, der sich diese Legislaturperiode damit beschäftigt hat, Digitalisierung und Geschlechterverhältnisse in den Blick zu nehmen. Genau, und da bin ich auch als Informatikerin. Das mache ich noch gerade.
Und Anke Domscheit-Berg, die ist Bundestagsbeauftragte, wollte ich gerade sagen. Mitglied des Bundestages ist der offizielle Titel. Und ich habe schon gelernt, bei solchen Menschen kann man nicht fragen, was machst du sonst noch? Deswegen, Anke, an dich die Frage, was machst du da spezifisch? Was sind deine Themen?
Da kann man ja auch ganz viel erzählen. Also zum einen bin ich netzpolitische Sprecherin der Linksfraktion im Bundestag. Ich bin Opfrau im Ausschuss Digitale Agenda. Ich war zwei Jahre lang in der Enquete-Kommission Künstliche Intelligenz und habe die Projektgruppe Künstliche Intelligenz und der Staat geleitet, wo das Thema des heutigen Abends ganz häufig drin vorkam. Ich bin in der EUK-Kommission des Bundestages. Das ist die, die sich mit der IT im Bundestag beschäftigt. Und ich bin im Beirat der Bundesnetzagentur. Wahrscheinlich hab ich noch was vergessen.
Auf jeden Fall sozusagen für unsere Sendung hier vom Fach. Und vielleicht mit der einen oder anderen Anekdote gesegnet. Mal sehen. Außerdem noch Matthias Marx in seines Zeichens CCC-Sprecher, also im Chaosradio, einer der Sprecher vom Chaos Computer Club. Und was machst du sonst noch so?
Ja, moin, ich bin ansonsten auch wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter an der Universität Hamburg und beschäftige mich auch da mit IT-Sicherheit und Anonymität im Internet.
So, also eine lustere Runde, die wir hier versammelt haben. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Ich werde versuchen, diese Sendung zu steuern, zusammenzufassen und zu verstehen, was hier eigentlich passiert. Es geht ja, wie gesagt, darum, dass es gerade eine Kampagne gibt, die Unterschriften sammelt für eine gesetzliche Regulierung von Biometrie und biometrischer Überwachung im öffentlichen Raum. Und wir machen das heute Chaosradio-Style, wie wir das immer machen. Wir fangen ganz von vorne an und am Ende wisst ihr dann alles oder habt zumindest sehr viel Grundlagenwissen über dieses Thema. Und über Netzpolitik haben wir schon häufiger geredet. Wir fangen in der technischen Seite an und fragen erst mal, was ist denn überhaupt Biometrie? Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Wer möchte anfangen?
Andrea vielleicht.
Ja genau, da fange ich mal an. Was ich eben vorher nicht gesagt habe, ich habe meine Doktorarbeit auch über biometrische Fingerabdruckerkennungssysteme geschrieben. Genau, das ist glaube ich der Grund, warum ich hier heute mitsitze. Das ist vielleicht noch eine wichtige Ergänzung. Also Biometrie ist im weitesten Sinne biologische Statistik, also Vermessung alles Organischen. Und im engeren Sinne, worüber wir heute reden, ist es die automatische Personenerkennung anhand von eindeutigen, universellen und möglichst unveränderlichen Körpermerkmalen oder Verhaltensmerkmalen. Genau.
Wie man das macht, fangen wir gleich an. Warum wird das eigentlich benutzt? Also die Überwachung ist natürlich die eine Sache, die diskutieren wir heute, aber warum wurde das überhaupt eingeführt? Weil die andere Nutzungsart, die man davon kennt, ist ja wahrscheinlich, dass man jetzt irgendwo so ein Gerät hat, was gesagt Fingerabdruck, es gibt ja Fingerabdrucksensoren, eben an vielen Geräten mittlerweile, per Gesichtserkennung wird das auch gemacht. Warum ist das überhaupt etabliert worden? Also warum macht man das?
Soll ich gleich mal antworten?
Gerne.
Okay, also um Menschen wieder zu erkennen, die man eigentlich nicht kennt. Also das ist vor allen Dingen im Kontext von Vertragsabschlüssen, oder im Rahmen der Kriminalitätsbekämpfung schon vor zweihundert Jahren ungefähr ins Rollen gekommen, die ganze Biometriegeschichte. Und ja, also wenn man eine dritte Instanz irgendwie hat, die eine Person nicht erkennt, dann ist Biometrie interessant.
Ich hatte jetzt eigentlich sozusagen nach den privaten Anwendungen, also die Anwendung vor dem Privatbereich, gefragt. Und da ist es sozusagen, das ist doch, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, umgedreht, oder? Da geht es ja genau darum, genau die Person wiederzuerkennen, die man kennt, weil die darf das Gerät bedienen und die anderen dürfen es aber nicht.
Ja klar, aber da ist eben, stimmt, ja genau. Aber man hat sozusagen ein Gerät, was einen quasi nicht kennt.
Das lernt einen kennen dadurch.
Das lernt einen kennen und man muss sich gegenüber diesem Gerät immer wieder, oder einmal bekannt, eigentlich immer wieder bekannt machen.
Aber es ist schon eher eine Gesichtsbestätigung und keine Gesichtserkennung, ne? Ich bestätige ja nur, dass es das Gesicht ist, von dem ich behaupte, es zu sein. Das mit der Berechtigung.
Ja, also das geht vielleicht in die Richtung, was du sagst. Das eine ist eben eine Bestätigung, eine Verifikation. Das ist das, was man dann am Smartphone immer macht. Oder wenn man in seine Firma, wenn man eine Grenze überquert mit seinem Pass, dann ist das eine Verifikation. Und eine Identifikation ist das, wo sich, glaube ich, auch das Reclaim Your Face vor allen Dingen gegenrichtet. Also, dass aus einer riesigen Masse von Menschen, Personen, Einzelnen erkannt werden, wer die sind.
Genau, ich wollte mal nur anfügen, wenn du meintest, fangen wir doch mal ganz bei der Grundlage an. Und apropos häppchenweise Vorstellungen, also mein Spezialgebiet ist Hochdatenschutz und IT. Was vielleicht auch einer der Gründe ist, warum ich hier bin. Wenn wir auf das Wort gucken, dann haben wir ja irgendwie Biometriene mit Bios, das Leben und Metri oder Metros, glaube ich, ist dann das Abmessen. Und da kann man so ein bisschen sagen, manchmal werden so bestimmte Lebensmerkmale vermessen. Und es kann irgendwie medizinischen Kontext, kann das irgendwie eine Herzschlag, irgendwelche Gehirnwellen oder so. Aber eben auch körperliche Merkmale, Andrea eben auch gesagt hat so. Interessant für die Anwendung, also eine der frühesten Anwendungen, ist so, ich glaube, vor 6000 Jahren, in China schon, wurden Verträge mit Fingerabdrücken besiegelt. Da konnte man dann quasi später, können wir später noch mal drüber sprechen, wie lange so ein Fingerabdruck gleich bleibt, wenn die Person dann gesagt hat, was, dieses Haus, das habe ich nie verkauft. Und wenn der andere dann den Vertrag herholt, dann wird quasi vor Gericht, wurde dann eben entschieden, ist das der Fingerabdruck, der da drauf ist oder nicht. Und da erkennt man schon den Nutzungshintergrund eigentlich, was vorhin so auch beschrieben worden ist, man will halt eine Person wiedererkennen, die irgendwas, also man will irgendwie, die kommt irgendwann mal wieder und man will sagen, das ist die gleiche, wie es vorher war. Und das ist heute ja auch nicht anders.
Na ja, doch, weil beim Reclaimer-Face geht es ja eigentlich um was anderes. Also geht es schon um den Wiedererkennen, aber es ist ja, es war ja sozusagen vor 6000 Jahren und so ist es ja auch, wenn ich die Biometrie privat in meinem Gerät benutze, ist es ja, ich gebe das einmal freiwillig ab und dann kann daran, also entweder hilft mir das oder sozusagen, in deinem Beispiel hilft es mir nicht so viel, sondern ich werde damit sozusagen erwischt, werde ich damit wiedererkannt. Bei dem öffentlichen Raum geht es ja eher sozusagen, das ist vielleicht das Neue in unserer modernen Zeit, dass ich die Daten gar nicht freiwillig abgegeben habe, weil der Fingerabdruck früher war immer auch, also bis zur Verbrecherdatenbank, eher was Freiwilliges. Mann, jetzt sind wir aber schon mitten in der politischen Diskussion. Ich wollte erst mal bei der Biometrie bleiben, so schnell kann es gehen. It's a slippery slope. Also Biometrie ist, jetzt hör auf, wir bleiben jetzt erst mal bei der Technik. Biometrie ist also die Vermessung des Menschen, kann man sagen, mit dem Ziel, eine Übereinstimmung, eine Wiedererkennung, eine Identifikation zu leisten. Welches der vielen verschiedenen körperlichen Merkmale, die es gibt, ist denn das, was am einfachsten zu messen ist? Also ich will jetzt Biometrie tatsächlich nicht nur im großen Jahrtausendehistorien-Kontext, sondern wie wir es heute haben, nämlich mit Übersetzung ins Digitale. Also Aufnahme durch ein digitales Gerät oder ein Gerät, das digitale Daten erzeugt, also eine Kamera oder ein Abtast-Laser oder wer weiß was es noch gibt. Und dann halt Datenverarbeitung. Was sind denn da klassische biometrische Merkmale und warum?
Also ich, ja am einfachsten würde ich jetzt sagen, ist tatsächlich das Gesicht mit. Also die klassischen Merkmale sind eigentlich ihres Fingerabdruck natürlich und Gesicht. Es gibt ja noch viel mehr. Reiner hatte auch Herzschlag gesagt, Wehnerkennung, Tasten, Anschlag und so weiter. Aber das sind so die drei großen, die immer gesagt werden, die auch ganz, ganz gut sind. Und Gesicht ist halt deswegen interessant, zumindest aus Sicht der Biometriker innen, weil es so widerstandslos erfasst werden kann. Also es ist nicht invasiv, man muss nichts berühren. Es kann ohne das Wissen, wie du gesagt hast, der Person, die da erfasst wird, aufgenommen werden. Also von der Einfachheit her gesehen ist das Gesicht natürlich super interessant.
Aber was genau heißt denn Gesichtserkennung? Also das ist ja eine riesige Fläche. Ich vermute viele Datenpunkte, was genau wird da aufgezeichnet, vermessen und woraus wird dann Identität erzeugt? Aber wenn du es nicht weißt, weiß das niemand.
Na ja, doch. Also das ist halt auch ein weites Feld. Also das ist eben wie sozusagen was, was im, glaube ich, im allgemeinen, ja, so im allgemeinen Diskurs immer präsent ist. Es ist ja ganz oft, man hat so ein Gitternetz über dem Gesicht liegen. So würde ja Gesichtserkennung ganz oft visualisiert. Das ist halt so ein bisschen merkmalbasierte Gesichtserkennung, sagt man. Und das gibt auch eine richtige Methode. Das heißt Elastic Bunch Graph Matching, wo man wirklich so ein Gitternetz, also ein Graphen übers Gesicht auch dann im Erkennungsverfahren legt und dann im Prinzip die verschiedenen, also die Augen, die Ohren, die Gesichtsformen, damit also als Graph erfasst werden geometrisch. Und da wird im Prinzip die Gesichtsmetrik gemessen. Es gibt aber ganz viele andere Verfahren, die sogenannten holistischen Verfahren, die wiederum...
Ich will noch kurz zur Frage, wenn du Metrik sagst, was meinst du dann? Meinst du dann irgendwie der Abstand zwischen den Pupillen oder wird irgendwie auch die Wölbung der Nase gemessen? Oder was genau sind da sozusagen? Also wie werden diese Punkte übersetzt? Also ist das ein 3D-Bild? Kann ich mir jetzt sozusagen wie so eine 3D-Gipsform vom Gesicht in Datenpunkten vorstellen? Oder was heißt ein Gesichtskraft?
Naja, das kann ganz normal 2D sein. Tatsächlich ist es wirklich wie so ein Gitter, was man übers Gesicht legen kann. Und die Abstände ergeben sie, also die Abstände zum Beispiel zwischen den Knoten. Also dann hat man zum Beispiel eben in den Augen sind die Knoten. Wenn man das jetzt wirklich so als Gitter sieht, liegen dann da die Gitterknoten halt. Und dann sind die Kanten zwischen denen, die verringern oder verlängern sich, je nachdem, wie die... Das kann man ja auf eine zweidimensionale Ebene ablegen.
Also jetzt ganz plump gefragt. Heißt das also, das misst, keine Ahnung, Abstand zwischen den Pupillen und von den Pupillen zur Nasenspitze. Und das macht das halt bei vielen Gesichtern. Und dann vergleicht das sozusagen, dieses neue Gesicht, was ich jetzt sehe, ist der Abstand zwischen den Pupillen und der Nasenspitze genau derselbe. Und wenn ja, dann ist es das Gesicht. Also ganz vereinfacht.
Das ist ganz vereinfacht, kann man das so sagen. Wobei genau diese Verfahren halt extrem unzuverlässig sind. Also wenn es genau so gemacht wird, dann stört sofort eine Lichtveränderung, eine Winkelveränderung und so weiter. Also deswegen ist sowas, wird nie, also so ein reines geometrisches Verfahren wird man auch nie alleine finden. Und ist heute auch eher unüblich geworden. Andererseits, also zum Beispiel diese Face-ID vom iPhone, das arbeitet dann auch schon mit Abstandsmessung zum Gesicht. Also das arbeitet dann schon eher auch, also da wird sozusagen eine 3D-Ebene mitgedacht. Das funktioniert ja dann wiederum mit Infrarotpunkten, die auf das Gesicht projiziert werden. Und dann lässt sich eben auch die Zeit, die das Licht braucht, messen. Ja, deswegen kann man das auch nicht so einfach austricksen mit einem Blatt Papier.
Dazu kommen wir gleich, wie man das austrickst. Jetzt hast du gesagt, es gibt diese einfache Messung, und dann hast du gesagt holistisch?
Ja, so heißen halt alle die Verfahren, die im Prinzip nicht mehr in diesem Bereich funktionieren, so wie wir uns das noch vorstellen können. Also die Abstände von Augen oder zur Nase oder zum Mund werden gemessen, sondern das sind dann Signalverarbeitungsalgorithmen, die halt wirklich so die Pixel des Bildes eher sehen. Also die zerlegen dann die einzelnen Pixel, die horizontalen und die vertikalen, also wirklich dann die 300 mal 300 Pixel in so Vektor-Räume oder machen so verschiedene Transformationen da drauf, dass man dann die in anderen mathematischen...
Mit Transformation meinst du, die Pixelflächen werden in Zahlen verwandelt und damit werden Dinge gerechnet?
Und dann kann man halt mit linearer Algebra da quasi ein bisschen drauf rumrechnen. Und dann gibt es dann so was Lustiges wie Eigenfaces, wo man dann so einen Eigenschaftsraum der Gesichter aufspannt, die man da als Trainingset reingibt. Und dann wird es zu erkennende Gesichter, da wird dann auch ein Eigenvektor drauf berechnet und wird in diesen trainierten Raum projiziert. Und dann wird die Position in diesem Vektorraum im Prinzip genutzt, um Ähnlichkeiten festzustellen zwischen zwei verschiedenen Gesichtern. Also das ist jetzt, glaube ich, nicht so. Ich habe auch vorher überlegt, wie erklärt man das plastisch. Also vielleicht grundsätzlich, da werden verschiedene mathematische Operationen ausgeführt, die im Prinzip die Pixel zerlegen.
Und ich finde an dieser sehr schönen Beschreibung, also man kann sich so vorstellen wie so ein 3D-Raum und jede Gesichtsaufnahme ist da in irgendeiner Stelle. Dann kann man so ein bisschen sagen, wenn die näher beieinander sind, dann sind die ähnlicher. Und daran erkennt man schon so eine schöne Eigenschaft der Biometrie. Die ist nämlich nie exakt, sondern es sind immer nur Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Und man kann dann eben sagen, ich habe hier ein Foto aufgenommen und da ein Foto aufgenommen, dann mache ich da die mathematische Zauberei und gucke im Vektoraum, die sind so und so weit voneinander weg. Und jetzt muss ich irgendwie entscheiden, sind die so dicht dran, dass ich die als die Gleiche behandle oder nicht? Und da erkennt man schon so ein, wie sozusagen, wo das Ende dieser Exaktheit da aufhört. Weil ich muss mich irgendwann festlegen und sagen, die Bilder sind so dicht beieinander, dass ich sie jetzt als die Gleichen behandle und sage, das ist die gleiche Person. Oder ich bin halt sehr picky dabei und sage, nee, ich will es ganz exakt machen. Und dann gibt es aber vielleicht auch Bilder in verschiedenen Situationen, das ist die gleiche Person, aber das Bild ist nicht dicht genug dran in dieser mathematischen Welt, dass ich es als gleich behandle. Ich muss da so eine Entscheidung treffen.
Das heißt, alle Verfahren, also wenn man Menschen ein Foto zeigt und sagt, ihr kennt sie diesen Typen, dann sagen die ja ja oder nein. Oder sie sagen, könnte sein, bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Es gibt sozusagen nur drei Zustände. Und sozusagen in digitalen biometrischen Systemen ist es also so, das System sagt eigentlich, also dem zeigst du ein Bild und eigentlich sagt es bei jedem anderen Bild, das ist keine 100%ige Übereinstimmung. Und dann musst du also sagen, naja, liebes System, sagen wir mal, 98, 7% ist genug. Und alles, was da sozusagen drüber ist, also 88, 8, 88, 9 und so weiter und so fort, das zählen wir als dasselbe gesicht und der Rest nicht. Das ist so die grundlegende, okay.
Ja, das ist dann dieser berühmte Schwellwert. Der wird auch hin und her verschoben, quasi als Parameter der Matching Engine. Und das ist auch immer ein Kompromiss zwischen Faults Positives und Faults Negatives, die am Ende bei diesem Muster abkommt.
Also das heißt, das können wir mal festhalten. Also biometrische digitale Systeme können nicht sagen, das ist dasselbe Gesicht. Die können nur sagen, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es dasselbe Gesicht ist, ist sehr hoch. Jetzt?
Da kann ich noch was hinzufügen. Es gibt ja verschiedene Merkmale. Das ist zum Beispiel beim Fingerabdruck auch so. In der Regel wird gesagt, wir brauchen zwischen 8 und 15 Punkte auf dem Finger, die sich wiederfinden, damit wir sagen, das ist das Gleiche. Bei vielen Verfahren gibt es diese Schwellwerte. Das ist auch nicht nur beim Gesicht so. Man kann vielleicht noch sagen, so was wie DNS-Analysen, die sind schon sehr exakt, aber die brauchen wiederum immer, die Analyse braucht ein paar Tage. Deswegen ist das kein sehr gutes oder praktikables biometrisches Merkmal in der Form. Aber ich wollte nur sagen, das ist bei anderen auch so.
Ich hätte jetzt mal eine Frage an Anke und Matthias. Und zwar, weil ihr beide mit einer fokussierten oder größeren Öffentlichkeit arbeitet. Anke, du sozusagen am Bundestag mit anderen PolitikerInnen. Diese grundlegenden Sachen über, wie Biometrie technisch funktioniert und die Tatsache, dass es eben keine hundertprozentige Übereinstimmung gibt, sondern dass das im Prinzip ein Wahrscheinlichkeitsspiel ist. Ist das auch der Konsens, auf dem politisch diskutiert wird? Oder fehlt es da an Fachwissen? Also der Bundestag besteht irgendwie aus mehreren Hundert Abgeordneten. Dass das da nicht jeder weiß, okay. Aber es gibt...
Die weit überwiegende Mehrheit dürfte das nicht wissen. Also die weit überwiegende. Ich würde mich jetzt nicht festlegen, es sind so gut 700 Abgeordnete. Ich würde mal sagen, so 670 wissen es wahrscheinlich nicht. Vielleicht verschätze ich mich um 20.
Du bist dir 70% sicher.
1, 8, genau. Okay, das war tatsächlich keine rhetorische Frage. Weil ich finde, dass wenn man politisch über ein Thema redet, das ist mir leider im Rahmen der Pandemie immer mehr und immer wieder schmerzhaft klar geworden, muss man manchmal hinterfragen, reden wir eigentlich über dasselbe? Also wissen eigentlich alle dasselbe. Das finde ich gerade in diesem Bereich auch spannend.
Aber es können auch gar nicht. Das sollte ich vielleicht, weil sonst alle Leute denken, die im Bundestag sind nur doof. Das muss man insofern korrigieren, als wir ja einerseits ein Arbeitsparlament sind. Das heißt, die hauptsächliche Arbeit findet gar nicht da im Plenum statt, wenn Reden ausgetauscht werden und Fragen gestellt, sondern in den Ausschüssen. Und in den Ausschüssen ist ja nicht jeder in allen Ausschüssen. Und es kann auch nicht jeder von allen Themen Ahnung haben. Das heißt, wie genau Biometrie Wahrscheinlichkeiten berechnet, wird im Leben niemand wissen, der im Sozialausschuss sitzt. Das sind dann die im Digitalausschuss. Das ist dann aber nur ein kleines Subset. Weil es geht wirklich in jedem einzelnen Fachausschuss so tief in die Spezifika hinein. Du kannst die anderen Fachbereiche nicht in der Tiefe kennen.
Das wär wirklich zu viel verlangt. Also das ja. Das ist tatsächlich die Arbeitsweise unseres Parlaments. Und manchmal ist das schwer zu ertragen. Aber so ist es halt tatsächlich. Was ich aber mein, ist Folgendes. Wir reden jetzt sozusagen grob 20 Minuten. Und finde, haben sozusagen eine ganz wichtige Grundlage erklärt. Und wenn man die politische Diskussion verfolgt von Menschen, die für mehr Überwachung sind, hat man halt oft den Eindruck, dass das sozusagen gar nicht mehr Teil der Diskussion ist. Dass also die Tatsache, dass so ein System das gar nicht erkennen kann, sondern immer nur sagen kann, es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass das gar nicht drin ist. Oder umgedreht zu formulieren, meine Erwartung ans Parlament wäre eigentlich folgende. Dass es eben genau Ausschüsse gibt, in denen Spezialthemen gesprochen werden. Und dass dann die Abgeordneten, die da sitzen, das Wissen haben. Und dann ihre KollegInnen dahingehend informieren über diese wichtigen Grundlagen.
In der Praxis wird es auch nicht funktionieren. Wir haben eine agrarpolitische Sprecherin, die genau weiß, was es mit der Ferkelkastration auf sich hat. Die erklärt mir das auch nicht. Wenn ich sie frage, macht sie das. Aber sie macht es nicht von alleine. Dann würde ich von morgens bis abends nur noch damit zu tun haben, dass mir spezielle Dinge aus anderen Fachbereichen erklärt werden. Ich bin froh, wenn ich es meins halbwegs schaffe. Wie kommt man da zu einer Abstimmungsverhaltung? In der Regel sind es die Fachpolitiker, die das Abstimmungsverhalten steuern. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Ferkelkastration. Ich höre auf in dem Fall Kirsten Tackmann. Wenn die mir sagt, das ist gut, dann weiß ich, die hat Ahnung. Das wird stimmen, das erwarte ich umgekehrt auch. Bei Digitalthemen möchte ich diejenige sein, die sagt, so ist die linke Position. Dann müssen die mir das einfach glauben, wenn sie es selber nicht besser wissen. Was ich viel schlimmer finde, als den Umstand, dass nicht alle jedes Fachliche in die Tiefe nachvollziehen können, ist, dass wir z.B. in einer Enquete-Kommission Künstliche Intelligenz haben wir 2 Jahre zusammengesessen. Das war genug Zeit, um selbst, wenn man von anderen Hintergründen kommt, sich da einzuarbeiten. Wir haben ja auch ganz viele Fachvorträge bekommen. Und so weiter und so fort. Trotzdem findet sich dann im Abschlussbericht der Enquete-Kommission zum Thema Südkreuz. Wir haben das also länglich in meiner Projektgruppe. Ich hab die geleitet von KI und Staat.
Stopp, du musst ganz kurz überrechnen. Für Leute, die es nicht vorhören, hat das Thema Südkreuz ein Prototypenprojekt zur Erforschung zur biometrischen Überwachung stattgefunden, wo also biometrische Systeme installiert wurden und dann geguckt wurde, wie gut sind die.
Genau. Es ging um Gesichtserkennung per aufgehängten Kameras mit freiwilligen Probanden, die interessanterweise vorher hochauflösend fotografiert wurden. Ist jetzt nicht sehr realistisch, wenn man nach Verbrechern fahndet. Aber sei es drum. Auf jeden Fall war es besonders in der Kritik, weil es so viele sogenannte False Positives hatte, was mit dieser Wahrscheinlichkeit zu tun hat.
Also False Positives ist das System, hat gesagt, ha ha, da hab ich ihn erkannt, aber es stimmt gar nicht.
Fälschlich gesagt, das ist die Person. Obwohl das System sagt er möglicherweise gar nicht mit 78, 34%, sondern es sagt, du, das ist der gesuchte Bindladen. Und dann ist er das aber gar nicht. Und das wurde ja unter anderem vom CCC kritisiert. Die haben also ausgerechnet, dass wenn 90.000 Leute da am Bahnhof Südkreuz herumlaufen, nach den Ergebnissen dieses Pilotprojektes würden dann jeden Tag 600 Leute falsch verdächtigt. Mal hochgerechnet auf 12 Millionen Bahnreisenden. Die Bundesregierung hatte zwischenzeitlich ja die Idee, an großen Bahnhöfen überall sowas aufzubauen. Während das 12.000 Menschen jeden Tag, die unschuldig, unter Verdacht stehen. Deswegen hatte ich in meinen Berichtentwurf reingeschrieben, genau diese Dinge, dass es also eine ganz schlechte Idee war und auch ganz schlecht funktioniert hat. Im Abschlussbericht steht es anders drin. Da steht nämlich die falsche Positivrate des Gesamtsystems, das durch die verschiedenen getesteten Einzelsysteme zusammengesetzt wurde, lag nach deren Kombination durchschnittlich bei unter 0, 1%. Die haben genau gewusst, was sie da sagen. Ich erkläre gleich, was das ist. Aber sie haben sich es halt schön gerechnet. 0, 1% ist bei 12 Millionen immer noch echt viel. Aber es ist viel niedriger als der Prozentsatz, mit dem der CCC gerechnet hat. Die haben dort nämlich drei verschiedene Systeme getestet und haben einfach alle drei aufeinander addiert. Deswegen Gesamtsystem nach deren Kombination lag die Fehlerate nur noch bei 0, 1%. Aber ich war wie realistisch ist das denn? Wo hängen dann drei verschiedene Systeme, die man übereinander legt? Das tut man nicht. Aber so haben die, obwohl sie wussten, es ist ein schlecht gelaufenes Projekt, ein Antib Beispiel, haben sie es positiv in diesen Bericht reingeschrieben. Deshalb ich dann noch ein Sondervotum verfasst habe, wo das Gegenteil drin steht. Aber das finde ich dann richtig schlimm. Weil die wissen, was sie tun, sie machen es nicht.
Das wäre die eigentliche Frage gewesen. Die eigentliche Frage wäre nicht gewesen, kennen sich da alle aus? Die Frage ist, treiben alle, die sich auskennen, keinen Schindluder? Die Antwort darauf ist offensichtlich nein. Andrea hat sich auch zu Wort gemeldet, bitte.
Ja, so ein bisschen in die Richtung, was bringt es sich an, false positives und false negatives abzuarbeiten? Ich finde es auch sehr wichtig, immer darauf hinzuweisen, dass die Systeme teilweise große Fehlerraten haben. Aber es ist auch gefährlich, sich nur darauf zu kaprizieren, weil das sich gerade auch bei der Gesichtserkennung rasant ändert. Nämlich das dritte Feld, was ich vorhin nicht genannt hatte, der neuronalen Netze, die einfach in einer unglaublichen Geschwindigkeit die Fehlerraten verbessern. Gerade im Bereich der Gesichtserkennung. Das Problem ist natürlich auch bei so was wie Südkreuz, das stimmt völlig, was Anke gesagt hat, da waren ganz schlechte, false positive Ergebnisse, die da raus kamen. Aber das Problem ist ja noch zusätzlich, dass man ganz oft gar nicht weiß, was wird da für ein System gerade eingesetzt, welche Version dieses Systems. Also schon eine Version kann riesige Sprünge mit sich bringen in den Performance-Raten. Oder was ist eigentlich mit dem Menschenbild, was dahintersteckt, warum machen wir das alles? Diese Fragen werden dann ganz oft nicht mehr gestellt, wenn man sich an diesem tatsächlich auch manchmal ein bisschen Knoten im Gehirn erzeugenden Statistikproblem so lange aufhält.
Also heißt, willst du damit sagen, wenn man das Ding politisch-gesellschaftlich diskutiert, sollte man sich nicht auf die technische Zuverlässigkeit konzentrieren, weil das sozusagen nur eins von vielen ist, aber dann möglicherweise andere Diskussionspunkte verdeckt und in die Zukunft gesehen sich sowieso erledigen wird?
Ein bisschen ja, also nicht komplett. Es ist natürlich total wichtig, sich mit der Statistik da drin zu beschäftigen und auch zu verstehen, dass sozusagen eine bestimmte...
Meine Frage ist, ist die Befürchtung, sozusagen Leute, also AktivistInnen gegen Gesichtserkennung sagen, ha ha, eure Systeme sind gar nicht zuverlässig und dann sagen halt in zwei Jahren die Befürworter, sind sie jetzt nämlich doch und jetzt?
Ja, genau, also es läuft tatsächlich immer so... Das ist ein bisschen ähnlich, wie wenn ich immer nur versuche, darauf abzuheben, dass die Überwindungssicherheit nicht hinhaut, also dass ich es doch knacken kann und so. Also es ist einfach nur ein Angriffsvektor, um jetzt mal in der Sprache des Security Engineering zu bleiben.
Wir kommen jetzt zur Diskussion noch. Jetzt aber sozusagen das Thema schlägt jetzt schon Wellen. Matthias wollte erst auch noch was sagen.
Ja, also diese Systeme, die da genutzt werden, sind heute vielleicht noch fehleranfällig. Und das ist richtig, mit neuronalen Netzen zum Beispiel kann man die Fehlerrate sicherlich noch deutlich nach unten schrauben. Allerdings sind die Systeme, die irgendwie magisch trainiert werden, durchaus manchmal diskriminierend. Und das ist ein noch größeres Problem, weil man bei diesen neuronalen Netzen nicht mehr so einfach reingucken kann und gucken kann, was hat dieses System eigentlich gelernt?
Okay, Rainer?
Ja, ich wollte noch hinzufügen, man versteht es auch ein bisschen, also ich bin da schon dabei, bei dem Problem ist, mit einer Abschwächung und zwar also die letzten Untersuchungen wie am Südkreuz, das war so Biotep 2 2005, Flughafen Frankfurt, das war so Mainzer Bauhaupt 2006, also das ist schon besser geworden, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es morgen vor der Tür steht. Also ich finde auch, man muss sich mit der Frage beschäftigen, was passiert, wenn der ganze Kram richtig funktioniert, und es gibt auch Möglichkeiten, wie man das machen kann. Also in China werden jetzt viele Systeme, so multimodale Systeme eingesetzt, also dann wird dann einfach Gesichtserkennung, Kleidungserkennung und Gangerkennung kombiniert. Und dann kriegst du auch wirklich sozusagen die Fehler der einzelnen Systeme fahrt schiedendlich raus und Gangerkennung zum Beispiel funktioniert auch noch so gut. Also ich hoffe, hier kommt jetzt keiner auf Ideen. Funktioniert sogar nicht mal verstellen. Bei Gesichtserkennung macht man Schal drum unten Hut und fertig ist. Das geht bei Gangerkennung nicht mehr. Und das glaube ich ein bisschen das, was Andrea auch meint. Wenn wir uns jetzt hier so auf Gesichtserkennung einschießen, dann sagen die anderen, na gut, dann machen wir es halt anders. Also dann aufpasst ihr noch. Und die zweite Sache, auf die ich noch hinweisen wollte, das Einsatzszenario ist bei solchen Systemen unglaublich wichtig. Wenn ich weiß, dass bei einem System diesmal die Person davor steht, die ich in der Datenbank habe oder die ich erwarte, ist das ein ganz anderer Einsatzzweck, als wenn die Personen, die davor stehen, überwiegend nicht die sind, die ich suche. Und das ist das Beispiel, was du vorhin meintest, mit dem Telefon. Die Gesichtserkennung an so einem Telefon, die kann natürlich ganz anders, also da akzeptieren wir ganz andere Verhaltensweise, die können wir schärfer schalten und so weiter, weil ich quasi in 99 von 100 Fällen bin ich es tatsächlich wirklich selber. Das heißt, die Schlechterkennung von Fremdlich ist so super relevant. Also da ist es eher wichtig, dass wenn ich es bin, es wirklich auch aufgeht. Wenn ich, dann ist dann so irgendwie so eine Nichterkennungsrate oder Falscherkennungsrate von 5% oder so ist halt nicht.
Du meinst, beim Telefon akzeptiert man, wenn ich selber nicht wirklich erkannt werde, weil das bedeutet eben, dass nicht zufällig jemand anderes reingelassen wird.
Nee, eher andersrum. Es kommt gar nicht so oft vor, dass jemand anders das macht. Das heißt, das kann so lax ab werden. Ich will eher, dass immer, wenn ichs bin, es ganz schnell aufgeht oder entsperrt wird.
Das verstehe ich aber nicht, weil das würde ja bedeutend nicht nehmen im Zweifel im Kopf, wenn dann doch mal jemand anders mein Telefon in die Hand nimmt, dass das dann auch aufgeht.
Ja, aber es passiert ja nicht so oft. Das ist genau der Punkt. Ich muss mich entscheiden. Bei diesen Wahrscheinlichkeiten muss ich nicht so tief reingehen. Ich muss mich immer so ein bisschen entscheiden, will ich eher so eine Comfort-Ding, was ein bisschen laxer ist, aber mich dafür nicht nervt? Oder soll es eher so scharf geschaltet sein, auch aufs Risiko hin, dass ich mich selber manchmal aussprache?
Ich möchte Letzteres.
Oh Gott, das will ich. Genau, richtig, das will ich nicht. Und warum ich aber diesen Unterschied gerade aufmache, ist, wenn ich sozusagen ein System, was bei einem Telefon irgendwie gut funktioniert, wo ganz selten andere das mal in die Hand nehmen, wenn ich dieses System in so einem Delle, dann ist es plötzlich, genau das, was Anke vorher noch gesagt hat, dann ist es plötzlich total relevant, dass diese Nichterkennung, Schlechterkennungsraten, derer, die ich nicht suche, bei 1%, 5% sind. Wenn da Millionen Menschen vorbeigehen, und das sind alles Nichtgesuchte, dann ist diese Rate, diese fälschliche Erkennung, wird dir auf einmal mega wichtig. Und das ist ganz anders bei den Telefonen. Und dieser Unterschied, glaube ich, daran eben unterscheiden, ob man irgendwie so eine Sicherheits-Tür in einem Elektro-Kraftwerk, wie man die absichert, oder wie man so ein Tool baut, was irgendwie so an den öffentlichen Plätzen hält.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir begeben uns sehr tief in so einen Kaninchenbau hinein, wo ich doch gar nicht hinwollte. Anke noch ganz kurz herzu, und dann würde ich tatsächlich noch mal kurz zu den technischen Gegebenheiten kommen wollen.
Oha, kurz, ich wollte so viel sagen.
Wir haben noch Zeit, aber ich würde gerne erst das eine Thema melden.
Also wenn du versprichst, dass wir auf diese gesellschaftlichen Folgen nochmal zurückkommen, dann können wir jetzt auch gerne noch das Technische machen, aber vielleicht habe ich einen Aspekt, der tatsächlich gegen das Technische vielleicht sogar noch reinpasst. Der hat nämlich damit zu tun, dass es ja einen gewissen Bias gibt, also eine Verfälschung der Interpretation durch die Art des Lernens mit Daten oder mit der Zusammensetzung der Daten, mit denen solche Systeme trainiert werden. Das beeinflusst nämlich die Falscherkennungsraten. Das ist also diese sogenannte Diskriminierung durch Bias, durch einseitige Trainingsdaten, die insbesondere eine ethnische Komponente hat, eine Geschlechterkomponente. Das heißt, People of Color und Frauen gegenüber Männern werden häufiger falsch erkannt oder nicht erkannt oder zu unrecht verdächtigt. Insofern spielen natürlich auch in diesem Zusammenhang Zahlen eine gewisse Rolle, aber ich wollte eigentlich, das mache ich dann später, zu Dingen noch was sagen, die jetzt mit den Zahlen gar nichts zu tun haben. Da hat nämlich Andrea Recht. Es ist vor allem eine Frage des Menschen, welches...
Genau, was diese Bevorurteilung angeht, da gibt es die schöne Seifenspender-Geschichte. Es gab mal einen Seifenspender, der, ich glaube, über Infrarot funktioniert hat. Und dann stellte sich irgendwie schnell heraus, wenn man als er eingesetzt wurde, mal guck mal, irgendwie, wenn ich eine Haut habe, die nicht rein weiß ist, dann funktioniert der gar nicht. Und was war passiert? Beim Testen gab es halt nur weiße Leute. Und so entstehen auch in Trainingsdaten ganz schnell Vorteile, die sich dann weiter tradieren. Ich würde jetzt aber wirklich gerne noch mal zur Technik kommen, weil wir reden ja sozusagen, also wir reden über Metrie im Allgemeinen, aber dann auch über die Überwachung des öffentlichen Raums im Besonderen. Und Rainer hat jetzt gerade schon diesen Unterschied gemacht. Also ein Gesicht, was auch dicht vorm Gerät ist, ist vielleicht was anderes, da sind halt hunderte Leute drauf. Und ich würde jetzt gerne mal so ein paar technische Eckdaten abfragen. Im Wissen, das wird sicherlich alles einfach durch mehr Technik und mehr Rechenkraft und bessere Modelle vielleicht erschlagen, aber wie es sozusagen heutzutage aussieht. Das Erste, wenn wir davon reden, dass biometrisches System in Menschenmassen einzelne Menschen erkennen. Wie funktioniert das eigentlich? Ist das dann, nehmen die wirklich einfach das Bewegtbild? Oder ist es eigentlich so, dass da zwar eine Kamera filmt, aber die macht einfach ganz viele, möglichst hochauflösende Fotos von Einzelpersonen, die werden dann analysiert?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich weiß es jetzt genau nicht. Ich glaube, dass es Einzelfotos sind, die dann abgeglichen werden. Aber in dem Zusammenhang kann ich zumindest einen Hinweis auf eine hilfreiche Quelle geben. Wo man sich auch zu den aktuellen Erkennungsraten ganz gut informieren kann. Das sind die Veröffentlichungen vom National Institute for Standards and Technology, glaube ich. Also vom NIST, vom amerikanischen.
Vielleicht könntest du uns noch einen Link nach der Sendung zukommen lassen. Dann schicken wir dann in die Shownotes.
Genau. Die testen im Prinzip alle Biometriesysteme die ganze Zeit. Die haben einen ongoing Face Recognition Vendor Test. Und da kann jedes Unternehmen, jede Organisation, jeder Einzelentwicklerin, die da irgendwas in der Richtung programmiert, ihren Algorithmus dahinschicken und das testen lassen. Die testen das mit fertigen Data Sets und so. Und die haben auch welche für Beweegbildertests. Und ich habe heute nur mal kurz rüber geschaut, aber nicht geguckt, ob die jetzt Einzelbilder abgleichen. Aber ich würde es vermuten. Und die sind noch nicht so gut. Also Beweegbilder, da ist noch viel Spielraum nach oben. Das läuft so mäßig. Irgendwo hatte ich, glaube ich, die... Aber ich hatte mir irgendwie vorher noch die Erkennungsraten aufgeschrieben. Und das war halt nicht so überzeugend. Da muss noch ein bisschen was passieren. Jetzt, ach, ich hab's hier. Bei... bei...
Falsch, das findest, kannst du noch nachreichen. Die andere Frage ist ja, wenn überwacht wird an Plätzen, wie viel Technik muss man denn da heutzutage aufhören? Ist das so, man hängt da einfach so eine kleine Kamera rein und die funkt dann irgendwas irgendwo hin? Oder heißt das eigentlich, du brauchst so einen Scheinwerfer, der vielleicht am besten unsichtbares Licht, also fürs menschliche auch unsichtbares Licht macht, und eine hochauflösende 8K-Kamera und dann möglichst dicht dran an einem Gigabit Ethernet, einen riesigen Gaming-PC mit 40 Grafikkarten, um den Rechenaufwand zu lösen? Also wie viel ganz plastischer Hardwareaufwand muss man denn heutzutage betreiben für so was?
Also der Malog zum Beispiel, einer dieser vielen schon lange etablierten Firmen im Biometriebereich, wirbt damit, Ich hoffe damit, dass sie es schaffen, eine Milliarde Templates innerhalb einer Sekunde zu prozessieren auf einem herkömmlichen Blade-Server. Was auch immer sie damit meinen. Also auf so einem Server, den man in so einen Rack rein- und rausschieben kann. Also wenn man sich jetzt ein so ein Ding da mietet, wahrscheinlich in einem Rechenzentrum und die Software installiert, dann soll man angeblich eine Milliarde Bilder verarbeiten können pro Sekunde, was Werbung ist. Und wenn man jetzt in diese Face-Recognition-Wendetests reinguckt, dann ist es aber tatsächlich so, dass die Bearbeitung von Einzelbildern diese Abgleiche dauern wirklich wenige Millisekunden. Das geht schon relativ zügig. Und die testen sowohl mit, naja, die nehmen JPEG-Compressed 300x300-Pixel-Fotos, so unter 15 Kilobyte pro Foto. Also das ist...
Also die nehmen ein großes Bild, schneiden da die Gesichter aus und dann machen sie darauf Gesichtserkennung, oder wie?
Naja, bei den...
Also es gibt ein Bild von einem öffentlichen Raum, da sind 100 Menschen drauf. Wie wird da ein einziges Gesicht erkannt? Schneidet der Rechner sozusagen, versucht er erst zu erkennen, was sind Gesichter? Und macht dann kleine Bilder draus und dann werden die analysiert auf die Identifikation?
Also das mit den 300x300-Pixel? Ach so, wenn niemand anders, gerne bitte.
Also es gibt Gesichtersuchmaschinen, die das genauso machen. Die gucken einfach erstmal nach Gesichtern im Bild. Und wenn sie die Gesichter gefunden haben, schneiden sie die aus und machen darauf dann die Gesichtserkennung.
Genau. Und das ist natürlich auch wirklich so ein Punkt, weil du sozusagen nach so einem Wert fragst. Das kommt ja wirklich ganz doll davon an. Also du kannst auch sozusagen in Klammern dumme Kameras nehmen und dann irgendwo ein Rechenzentrum, wo das alles gemacht wird. Du kannst so in Einführungsstrichen smarte Camps nehmen, die schon mal eine Vorfilterung machen und nur die Gesichter weiter leiten und so weiter. Also da gibt es so verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie man das macht. Aber ich finde das sehr interessant, weil du schon angemerkt hast mit irgendwie hell und so. Also dieser Kontext ist sehr, sehr wichtig. Also auch wirklich so was wie Bildhintergrund und so. Damit kann man total viel, also es hängt sehr viel, die Erkennungsraten hängen sehr viel davon ab. Das war auch einer der Gründe, warum zum Beispiel am Südkreuz die gucken halt auf die Rolltreppen, wo die Leute stehen, irgendwie nach unten, weil so viel Smartphone gucken, aber die Leute stehen da in einer gut ausgeleuchteten Umgebung. Und das sind sozusagen sehr gute Voraussetzungen. Im Südkreuz war der Test natürlich total hingeschoben und total unwissenschaftlich gemacht, weil nämlich die Leute da irgendwelche Amazon-Gutscheine gewinnen konnten. Und deswegen, die die mitgemacht haben, selber aktiv in die Kameras geguckt haben, um den Gutschein zu gewinnen. Deswegen war das natürlich kein realer. Die Ergebnisse kann man da eigentlich überhaupt nicht benutzen.
Jetzt wird's doch schon wieder politisch. Ich wollte doch erst mal über die Technik reden.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte ja nur sagen, sie haben es sehr schlau gemacht, um möglichst gute Raten, um technisch sehr gute Raten zu bekommen, muss man dafür sorgen, dass die Leute möglichst gut und gerade in die Kamera gucken. Deswegen ist es auch immer ganz, wenn man Platz überwachen will, kann man auch an den Eingängen so Vereinzelungsanlagen machen und dann da die Kameras hinstellen und so. Man kann auch sogar die Plätze so bauen, dass dann die Überwachung besser funktioniert und so. Deswegen, es hängt von ganz vielen Faktoren ab, wie man das sagt. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht so ein Hexenwerk mehr heutzutage, so einen Platz auszuleuchten und abzufilmen.
Okay, also die Technik ist in einem Stadium, wo sie einsetzbar ist und das auch im öffentlichen Raum mit Aufwand, aber nicht mit unüberwindbar großem Aufwand. Die Erkennungsraten sind je nachdem so la la oder ganz schön schlecht. Ich würde noch kurz, bevor wir dann wirklich zur politischen und gesellschaftlichen Diskussion kommen, noch fragen, was es noch so gibt. Nicht im Sinne von welche andere biometrischen Merkmale, sondern in diesem Setting öffentlicher Raum. Und was man sozusagen versucht, noch mit biometrischen Daten zu retten. Sie haben ja schon gesagt, also man kann versuchen, am Gang Menschen zu erkennen. Und dann liest man ja immer wieder irgendwie, man kann die sexuelle Ausrichtung an Gesichtsbiometrie erkennen. Oder man kann Emotionen erkennen. Und dann geht natürlich in meinem Kopf dann sofort los, Moment mal, wenn ich jetzt so ein Typ bin, der denkt, Biometrieüberwachung macht Sicherheit, dann kann ich doch gleich gucken, ob ich nicht nur das Gesicht erkenne, sondern auch noch, ob der vielleicht gestresst ist. Weil dann will er vielleicht was Böses machen. Gibt es das schon?
Also, das wurde versucht. Es sollte ja auch beim Südkreuz eine zweite Phase geben, wo nicht nur Gesichtserkennung, sondern auch Verhaltenserkennung stattfinden sollte.
Okay, also es ist tatsächlich ein Ding, Verhaltenserkennung.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist so die Fantasie. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt angefangen hat, oder ob deswegen, da bin ich nicht ganz, ob das wegen Corona... Also es sollte, lange Zeit sollte es...
Das lief ein Jahr, aber das war sehr simplifiziert und lief von Sommer 2019 bis Ende 2019. Aber das war nicht wirklich im engeren Sinne eine Verhaltenserkennung, sondern es war darauf gepolt, zum Beispiel eine sich nicht bewegende, herumliegende Person festzustellen oder ein einsam herumstehendes Gepäckstück. Das ist jetzt nicht besonders hochwertig intelligent. Aber in Mannheim hat man so was geplant. Und da hat man das Projekt, meines Wissens, in der Mitte wieder eingestampft und dann nicht fortgeführt. Das ist auch Pi mal Daumen eineinhalb Jahre her. Ich habe jetzt nicht den alleraktuellsten Stand. Vielleicht ist es von den Toten wieder auferstiegen. Das gibt es ja öfter bei so Überwachungsdingern. Aber da sollten an sogenannten Gefährderplätzen intelligente Kameras Verhaltensauffälligkeiten beobachten. Und da geht es dann um Sachen wie rennt einer weg, prügeln sich Leute. Ist es eine potentiell gefährliche Situation nach Interpretation dieser intelligenten Kamera? Und die sollte sowas voridentifizieren, quasi Alarm schlagen, dabei aber nicht die Gesichter angucken, sondern halt das Verhalten, die Bewegungen. Und sollte dann quasi echte polizeiliche Menschen alarmieren, die dann da scharf schalten konnten durch die Kamera, dann gucken, was da genau passiert, und wenn da wirklich was los ist, irgendeine Streife hinschicken.
In Karlsruhe wird so ein Projekt gerade weiterverfolgt, also genau das gleiche Thema wie in Mannheim. Das Spannende in Karlsruhe ist zusätzlich, dass eine private Firma, ein eigentlich Energieversorger, das ganze System betreiben soll und auf die Bilder gucken soll. Und wenn was passiert, rufen die Beschäftigten dieses Energieversorgers die Polizei.
Okay, aber noch mal zurück zu der Frage, hat jemand nicht nur den Überblick über die Dinge, die in Deutschland schon am lebenden Patienten nicht einmal versucht werden, nämlich uns, sondern auch was wissenschaftlich noch versucht wird, über Biometrie zu erkennen? Weil ich kann mich nur dunkel an dieses eine Ding erinnern, wo ich glaube tatsächlich kriminelle Rückfallraten oder sowas erkannt werden sollten.
Das war ganz groß gelicht.
Am Gesicht sollte da irgendwie erkannt werden, ob jemand vielleicht zum Verbrecher wird. Und dann hat sich hinterher herausgestellt, dass das Trainingset, mit dem dieses System gefüttert wurde, sozusagen ganz hart bevorurteilt war und das ganze Ding in sich zusammengefallen ist. Gibt es sowas noch mehr?
Ich glaube, das war aber nicht Gesichtserkennung, sondern das hat andere Daten ausgewertet. Da wurden zum Beispiel Fragen gestellt nach Angehörigen und ob man in welchen Wohngebieten man wohnt. Und dann halt so aus Erfahrungsdaten extra poliert, nach dem Motto, aha, du kommst aus dem Ghetto und dein Bruder war auch schon mal am Knast. Dann wirst du bestimmt rückfällig und hat also so eine Art Sippenhaft oder Ortshaft gemacht. Und das muss ja schiefgehen. Aber was mir bei der Gelegenheit bei deiner Frage noch einfällt, was ich neulich gelesen habe, ist, dass man in China, die da ja besonders weit sind, nicht nur Gesichtserkennung da beim Ampelübergang macht, wo ein großes Video noch da angezeigt wird für alle Menschen, die da auch in der Nähe sind, und gesagt wird, hier du mit dem Name so und so, du bist bei Rot über die Ampel, du musst jetzt schnell eine Strafe zahlen, dann wird dein Foto hier wieder gelöscht und dann können die über Handy ihre Strafe zahlen. Aber es gibt auch einen biometrischen Einsatz in Schulen in China, wo man also Kindergesichter in der Schule beim Lernen beobachtet und daraus versucht zu interpretieren, ob sie gerade aufmerksam zuhören oder geistig abgedriftet sind und sich mental mit was anderem beschäftigen. Und das ist schon wirklich abartig, finde ich.
Das geht gar nicht. Ich will noch mal kurz zurückkommen, weil ich habe nebenbei noch mal geguckt, ich meine tatsächlich anhand von Gesichtsfotos. Darauf wollte ich... Es gab tatsächlich Forscher... Okay, du weißt das, erzähl mal.
Es gab da verschiedene Versuche, zum Beispiel so was wie eine sexuelle Orientierung, dass man merkt, die Person ist homosexuell oder die ist heterosexuell oder so weiter. Darüber so eine Sache zu finden, da gab es so eine Studie, aber die wurde im Endeffekt ziemlich kritisiert, weil es ein bisschen auch an der Qualität der Bilder war. Also sozusagen die von der einen Gruppe kamen aus einer anderen Quelle die Bilder als aus der anderen Gruppe. Da war nicht so ganz klar, ob der Unterschied wirklich die Gesichter sind oder ob der Unterschied sozusagen das Bildmaterial an sich ist. Kennt man ja so ein bisschen diese... Also was da manchmal bei Bilderkennung so für Fehler entstehen.
Knastfoto.
Ja, oder genau, oder irgendwie das eine... Die einen Pferde sind immer bei Sonnenschein geknackt, die Pferde immer bei Nebel und dann fragt man sich, was ist das teurere Pferd? Fühl ich die mit den besseren Bildern bei Sonnenschein? So was in diese Richtung. Aber das wurde ziemlich kritisiert. Was ich jetzt als letztes gesehen habe, war, das ist eine Studie vom 11. Januar 2021. Da ging es um Gesichtserkennung, die die politische Orientierung von natürlichen Gesichtsbildern erkennen kann. Das ist in Nature Scientific Reports erschienen. Michael Kosinski war das oder Michael. Da weiß ich noch nicht, das ist das Letzte, was ich jetzt gehört habe. Aber da habe ich jetzt die Diskussion noch nicht verfolgt. Ich wollte damit nur sagen, das wird probiert, was man alles aus dem Gesicht sozusagen rauslesen kann. Da weiß ich jetzt noch nicht, da habe ich jetzt noch keine Kritik davon gelesen oder Methodenkritik oder so. Kann man mal gucken, ist auch Open Access by Nature verfügbar. Aber nur als letzten Abschluss, da sind wir so ein bisschen abgebogen. Die Wünsche sind ja immer groß, was man mit dieser Erkennung so macht. Auch wenn es jetzt bei Südkreuz im Endeffekt nur um Koffer- und Personenströme ging, der Wunsch ist immer, welche Situationen zu erkennen. Das ist dann vielleicht ne Haltung in dem politischen Teil.
Ich möchte noch mal dabei bleiben.
Nein, nein, nein, ich meine die Technik. Ich meine schon die Technik. Ich habe dir nur die über nettem Angebot. Ich will da noch nicht hingehen. Man kann sich ja überlegen, jemand, der eine Geldbörse geklaut hat, der steht irgendwo rum und auf einmal rennt da los. Wenn ich allerdings gerade meinen Lieblingspodcast höre, zum Beispiel Chaos, und dann merke ich, oh Mann, mein Zug fährt vom anderen Gleis los, dann werde ich exakt gleich reagieren. Dann kann man sich die Frage stellen, was ist denn eine gefährliche Situation? Kann man sich ja überlegen, wie kann man denn eigentlich aus einer Außenbetrachtung einer Situation erkennen, ob die gerade gefährlich ist oder nicht? Da kommt man dann wirklich an die Grenzen der Technik. Das technisch Machbaren überhaupt.
Aber der Traum ist es immer. Das würde ich noch mal zurückkehren zu diesen ganzen Dingen, was man noch alles in Biometrie erkennen kann. Haltet ihr das auch für eine... Klar, die Situation, wie du sie beschreibst, unterschließt das ja bei diesen ganzen Versuchen. Sexualität, vermeintliche Kriminalität, vermeintliche Aufmerksamkeit, vermeintliche politische Orientierung. Glaubt ihr, dass das eine Frage der Technik ist? Also auch da sozusagen, wie bei den Identifikationsfehlerraten, das sozusagen geht irgendwann? Oder glaubt ihr, das ist was, das ist sozusagen auch so ein, keine Ahnung, Traum, den Menschen anscheinend immer haben, aber das ist eigentlich gar nicht möglich? Das ist glaskugelig, das ist mir klar, aber habt ihr dazu einen Educated Guest oder ein Gefühl?
Also ich glaube, es gibt durchaus auch positive Bereiche, die haben wir noch gar nicht von gesprochen, im Bereich Gesundheit, wo es tatsächlich Hoffnungen gibt.
Nein, stopp, das ist aber jetzt nicht die Frage. Die Frage ist sozusagen, diese Dinge, die da versucht werden, also politische Orientierung, etc. Glaubt ihr, dass man so was erkennen kann? Oder ist das sozusagen immer eigentlich eher so Taschenspielertrickkram?
Das ist komplett glaskugelig. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es geht.
Das ist ja so wie Howard's Dated, genau das, was Lombroso oder Francis Galton im 19. Jahrhundert oder im 18. Jahrhundert versucht haben.
Was haben die versucht?
Na ja, rauszufinden, wie man im Gesicht den typischen Verbrecher erkennt. Galton hat zum Beispiel die Komposit-Fotografie benutzt. Der hat dann mehrere Fotos übereinander gelegt von VerbrecherInnen, um dann zu sehen, wie sich in der Häufung der übereinander gelegten Fotos bestimmte Merkmale so stark zeigen, dass man sagen kann, jemand mit einer dicken Nase ist geborene Verbrecherin. Oder es ist auch Schädelvermessung, all diese Geschichten. Das ist genau das, was dann die böse Seite der Kriminalbiologie geworden ist und dann in die narzisstische Rassenlehre eingeflossen ist. Klar, das ploppt dann auch immer wieder auf. Das ist das Gepäck der Biometrie, das schwierige Gepäck. Ich finde, da muss man auch schon sehr genau fragen, was soll denn jetzt draus geschlossen werden? Soll das Geschlecht geschlossen werden? Oder soll die sexuelle Orientierung geschlossen werden? Oder eben die politische Haltung? Umso schwimmender wird es dann. Eine Geschlechtserkennung zum Beispiel ist schon wieder was, das möglich ist, aber sehr relativ in dem Maße, wie ich akzeptiere, dass Geschlechter konstruiert sind. Diese ganzen Kategorien, wo ich auch sagen kann, das sind Aushandlungspraktiken in Gesellschaft. Da spielen auch gesellschaftliche Machtverhältnisse eine Rolle. Die aus Körpermerkmalen rauszuziehen, ist äußerst schwierig und ist auch eigentlich nicht zulässig. Man kann sogar so weit gehen und zu sagen, die Personentität aus vermeintlich unveränderlichen Körpermerkmalen herauslesen zu wollen. Dieser Schluss, dass ich ich bin, aufgrund einer biometrischen Erkennung, ist auch schon eine Überinterpretation. Weil sozusagen der Teil, der da drin steckt, nämlich überhaupt zu sagen, es gibt eine Person, es gibt sowas wie eine feste Identität, die sich ein Leben lang nicht ändert, ist ja auch schon irgendwie so eine Zuschreibung, über die man durchaus diskutieren könnte. Was die Sozialwissenschaftler auch machen. Es gibt zum Beispiel von Valentin Gröbner so ein schönes Buch Der Schein der Person, wo darüber gesprochen wird, wie überhaupt die Idee der Person erst mit der Aufklärung entstanden ist. Ich finde, das ist so eine Begehrlichkeit, die drinsteckt in der Biometrie. Das finde ich auch gut, dass du es angesprochen hast, weil das ist genau das, was immer irgendwann kommt. Die biometrischen Verfahren werden ja vor allen Dingen eingesetzt, weil man sich nicht darauf verlassen kann, dass der andere wirklich der andere ist und nicht irgendwie ein Betrug stattfindet. Weil diese Idee, dass ich kennens, dass ich vertrauens, da gar keine Rolle mehr spielt. Und ich finde in diesem Zusammenhang auch immer total interessant diese Frage, warum kaufen denn so viele bei irgendwem, auf Ebay zum Beispiel, wir haben es heute noch bei uns, keine Ahnung, aber auf gutes Vertrauen hin, kaufen die irgendwas bei einer wildfremden Person und da passiert überhaupt keine biometrische Authentifizierung oder Identifizierung. Und in der Regel geht das gut. So wie in der Regel eben nicht alle einklaufen. In der Regel sind die Menschen ja nicht kriminell. Irgendwie geht menschliche Gesellschaft oder menschliche Gemeinschaft vor allen Dingen auch ohne solche maschinellen Verfahren, die feststellen, ob jemand richtig okay ist.
Also das heißt, Biometrie, wie wir sie heute besprechen, kann bestenfalls, und das momentan auch noch mit einer Fehlerrate, die mal mehr oder mal weniger groß ist, erkennen, ob derselbe physikalische Körper in Menschenform sich gerade in einem anderen Ort befindet. Und der Rest, also alles, was man da noch machen will, kann man eigentlich sagen, sagt mehr darüber, wie wir unsere Gesellschaft in Klassen unterteilt, als darüber, ob man das wirklich durch Technologie erkennen kann.
Wow, also das finde ich super formuliert. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir die anderen sehen, aber...
Alles klar. Weil Anke gerade angesprochen hatte, dass wir heute ein bisschen auf Biometrie rumhacken und biometrische Systeme, das wird gleich noch politisch, ob man zwischendurch sagen kann, ob es nicht eine Gutanwendung ist, kommen wir gleich zu dem, was sie gerade angesprochen hat. Ich wollte vorher noch mal in diesen Privatbereich reingehen. Und das ist ja biometrische Daten bei den eigenen Geräten benutzen für Zugangsbeschränkungen oder sowas. Und ich will jetzt eher idealisiert fragen. Also nicht irgendwie besteht die Gefahr, dass der Anbieter meines Geräts meine biometrischen Daten, sondern dieses Grundkonzept, wir gehen mal davon aus, die Geräte sind so konzipiert, dass die biometrischen Daten nur auf dem Gerät selbst stattfinden und nicht irgendwo hingeladen werden. Und das wird sozusagen als Komfortfunktion benutzt. Seid ihr dem gegenüber auch grundsätzlich ablehnend gegenüber? Oder sagt ihr, nee, so im privaten Bereich, wenn halt jemand irgendwie seine Hände damit entschlüsseln will und ihm halt klar ist, welche Risiken das mit sich bringt, dann soll er das halt machen. Oder sagt ihr, das ist so ein schleichendes Ding, Biometrie muss eigentlich immer, also darf nie nirgendswo stattfinden.
Ja, das frag ich mich auch immer.
Ich denke, wenn Menschen das aus Bequemlichkeit nutzen wollen, dann sollen sie das machen. Allerdings glaube ich, dass viele sich den Risiken gar nicht bewusst sind. Denn ich kann nicht gezwungen werden, ein Passwort einzutippen als Extrembeispiel. Aber wenn ich mein Handy mit meinem Gesicht entsperren kann, dann kann auch die Polizei mein Handy mit meinem Gesicht entsperren.
Na ja, klar. Deswegen war meine Frage sozusagen eine grundsätzliche. Passwort sind grundsätzlich eine gute Idee. Dann muss ich darüber aufgeklärt werden, dass 0000 kein gutes Passwort ist. Dann kann man auch sagen, Biometrie ist eine gute Idee. Aber vielleicht willst du lieber dein Handy per Passcode entsperren und dann da drin noch mal extra Dinge mit deinem Gesicht machen. Das meine ich damit, ob die Technologie grundsätzlich ablehnenswert ist.
Also ich kann da vielleicht noch was dazu sagen. Für mich ist die Frage, was für eine Datenverarbeitung steht da im Hintergrund? Ich guck da jetzt mit so einer Datenschutzbrille drauf und die guckt halt immer auf Machtasymmetrien zwischen den Beteiligten, wenn man jetzt mal so ein bisschen komplizierter ausdrücken will. Und dann merkt man, es ist einfach ein Unterschied, ob das Bild in meinem Handy gespeichert ist. Und ich kann es entsperren, aber es verlässt nie das Gerät. Und es ist auch hardwaremäßig so gebaut, dass es nicht das Gerät verlassen kann. Man kann nach den Snowden Revelations vertrauen. Aber das ist ein Unterschied zu einem verteilten Kamerasystem, was irgendwo zusammenläuft bei einer mächtigen staatlichen Organisation. Man könnte sich auch überlegen, dass irgendwie eine andere Firma, die ein Handy baut, die macht genau so eine Face ID, aber vom Telefon gemacht, sondern es wird zentral in den Zentrum gemacht. Wäre die gleiche Funktionalität, aber die würde ich komplett ablehnen. Und die andere würde ich sagen, na ja, okay. Also das ist so ein bisschen... Also für mich ist es nicht nur, was da konkret passiert, sondern welche Strukturen dahinterstecken.
Aber das heißt, ich habe ja gerade gefragt, nachdem sozusagen passiert... Also ich finde es nicht...
Ich finde es nicht grundsätzlich abzulehnen. Das wäre für mich nicht der Punkt. Aber in sowas wie öffentlichen Plätzen, wo staatliche oder auch Firmen das sozusagen auf so eine Art zentralisierte Art und Weise sammeln und auswerten und so weiter, da entsteht der große Unterschied. Das ist dann für mich der Punkt.
Aber die Antwort auf meine Frage ist dann, ja, das kann man schon mal machen.
Ich finde, das kann man schon mal machen, ja. Also es ist so ein Punkt. Wenn die Menschen tatsächlich eine echte Wahl haben, dann finde ich es okay. Aber man muss immer die Rahmenbedingungen auch betrachten. Haben sie wirklich eine Wahl oder wissen sie die? Was eben gesagt worden ist, kennen sie die Risiken nicht? Und können sie die überhaupt kennen?
Ich freu mich jetzt schon, das war ja die Prämisse meiner Frage. Und du sagst es trotzdem noch mal so ausführlich. Ist das so, weil deine Erfahrungen damit sind, dass das eigentlich nicht der Fall ist?
Dass die Leute sich da nicht auskennen? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wir haben ja gehört, es ist ja wie bei allen Datenschutzfragen, die größte Lüge des Internet ist die informierte Einwilligung. Also ist ja auch okay in einer arbeitsteiligen Gesellschaft. Das hat ja Anke sehr schön erklärt, wie auch der Bundestag eben arbeitsteilig funktioniert. Aber es ist natürlich, wenn man sagt, Face ID ist kein Problem und so weiter, die meisten Leute wissen natürlich nicht, wie es funktioniert und können deswegen die Fragen gar nicht abschätzen. Und es ist doch okay, wenn mein Hauptjob darin besteht, irgendwie Häuserfassaden mit Stuck zu verputzen, dann warum soll ich denn wissen, wie die funktionieren? Das ist glaube ich so der Punkt.
Okay, dann würde ich jetzt zu dem Punkt kommen, den Anke vorhin angesprochen hat. Nämlich, es gibt ja auch positive Anwendungsgebiete für biometrische Erkennung. Und wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, Anke, meintest du damit irgendwas im medizinischen Bereich.
Ja, ich habe vor ein paar Monaten mal eine sehr interessante Story gelesen über eine Parkinson-Früherkennung anhand der Stimminterpretation. Stimme ist ja auch Biometrie. Und da kam man in irgendein Tool, war noch im wissenschaftlichen Bereich, keine App, die man sich runterladen kann. Aber im Prinzip war es eine Art App. Die ist im Hintergrund mitgelaufen oder man hat ihr da spontan Dinge erzählt, das erinnere ich mich nicht mehr genau. Aber die hat sehr frühzeitig Veränderungen in der Stimme erkennen können. Offenbar hat man da so ein kleines, fängt die Stimme an, ein bisschen zu schleifen. Was man selber gar nicht hört, nicht mal die Bekannten und Verwandten nehmen die Differenz wahr. Aber dieser künstliche Intelligenz-Algorithmus hat die Veränderungen wahrgenommen und kann dann eine Warnung ausgeben, dass hier möglicherweise eine sehr frühe Form von Parkinson vorliegt. Und das fand ich eigentlich ganz interessant. Auch gerade in den letzten Monaten, durch die Medien gegeistert, ist auch so eine Anwendung auch noch auf Forschungsebene, wo man in sein Handy, in diese App hineinhusten konnte. Und dann hat es einem gesagt, ob man wahrscheinlich einen Covid-Husten hat, einen Corona-Husten oder irgendeinen Husten, Raucher-Husten oder keine Ahnung was. Und das war aber wohl noch in der frühen Phase. Da gab es auch Debatte darüber, wie gut die Daten waren. Aber das sind für mich interessante Anwendungsbeispiele, wo das durchaus auch Sinn machen kann. Aber da geht es eben auch nicht um die Identifizierung einer eigentlich anonymen Person, die das möglicherweise gar nicht möchte. Sondern es geht um erstens eine echte Einwilligung und dann um etwas, ich kann das ja auch anonym machen, meine Stimme da testen lassen oder meinen Husten. Da muss ich ja nicht mal die Identität auflegen. Und was ich da mit der Information mache, ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. Also für mich sind das positive Anwendungsbeispiele.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Gemeinsamkeit ist auch wirklich, das macht man dann halt auch mit Absicht. Und das wird dann nicht irgendwie überläufen. Rainer, du wolltest auch noch?
Ja, das finde ich ein schöner Bogen zu dem, was Andrea auch vorhin gesagt hat. Ich glaube, zum Beispiel die Biometrie jetzt, das ist halt ein visuelles Verfahren, womit wir Körper beobachten. Und deswegen können wir sehen, ob die Leute irgendwie Augenringe haben oder ob sie halt in der Stimme früher Anzeichen von Parkinson. Was wir damit eben nicht können, ist geistige Werte irgendwie auslesen. Oder zumindest ist es sehr, sehr schwierig. Und dann müssen wir ganz genau hinschauen, weil wir sonst in diese dunkle Geschichte wieder zurückkommen. Das heißt, sowas wie ist jemand ein Verbrecher, Verbrecherin? Oder ist jemand aggressiv oder gefährlich oder irgend sowas? Da kann man genau sehen, das ist eben keine, das ist ja erstmal nicht direkt eine körperliche Eigenschaft, sondern es ist eine geistige Eigenschaft. Die kann vielleicht körperliche Anzeichen haben und dann muss man überlegen, ob man die erkennen kann. Aber was jemand im Schilde führt, das waren ja so die dunklen Beispiele, das ist eben eine geistige Eigenschaft. Ob die jetzt körperlich abzulesen, das fällt uns ja als Menschen selbst schwer. Siehe Kommunikationsprobleme und so weiter. Also das glaube ich ist genau dieser Übergang. Man kann feststellen, ob jemand rennt. Aber was das bedeutet, dass die Person rennt, das ist im Bild in der Regel nicht zu erkennen.
Es gibt noch ein schönes Beispiel. Ein Supermarkt hat kürzlich damit beworben, dass man da jetzt sein Gesicht scannen kann und die Anwendung sagt der Person dann, welches Gemüse die Person doch mal essen sollte. Ich habe mir diese Anwendung mal angeschaut und in Wahrheit, also die Anwendung verarbeitet tatsächlich ein Gesicht, soweit war es nicht gelogen. Die Anwendung schätzt dann Geschlecht mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit und das Alter des abgebildeten Gesichts. Und dann wird man auf eine Seite weitergeleitet, wo in Abhängigkeit von der Zeit irgendein Gemüse angezeigt wird. Da spielten die vorgenannten Faktoren gar keine Rolle mehr. Das heißt, zu Werbezwecken werden da völlig falsche Erwartungen auch geweckt.
Da wüsste ich ja echt gerne mal, was so alte Damen im Vergleich zu jungen Männern angeboten kriegen. Die einen Paprika, die anderen Möhrchen oder was?
Das klingt jetzt eher nach, das war völlig irrelevant. Die wollten nur die Daten haben und haben danach ein zufälliges Gemüse gezeigt.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Matthias, kannst du noch mal genau sagen, wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe, haben diese biometrischen Daten keine Rolle gespielt bei der Auswahl des Gemüses. Dann hast du gesagt, in Abhängigkeit von der Zeit.
Das heißt, auch wenn ich das gleiche Gesicht noch mal hochgeladen hab, wurde mir irgendwann später am Tage anderes Gemüse hochgeladen, äh, gezeigt. Und für viele verschiedene Gesichter...
Ach, von dem Gemüse war noch zu viel da. Das wird es gewesen sein.
Ja.
Das Gemüse musste weg.
Und gleichzeitig wurde mir für viele verschiedene Gesichter zum gleichen Zeitpunkt immer das gleiche Gemüse angezeigt.
Das bestätigt meinen Verdacht.
Die Karotten müssen weg.
Ja, keine Lebensmittelverschwendung.
Aber es ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür, wie man eben diese Art von Traumerwartungen weckt, als könne man das machen.
Wäre ich auch anfällig für, sozusagen. Ich tue mich schwer mit gesunder Ernährung. Gerade weil es heutzutage wenig andere Späße gibt, die man treiben kann. Aber wenn mir dann sozusagen so ein quasi-neutrales System sagen würde, Markus ist doch mal eine Möhre.
Also bei Pflanzen funktioniert das ja. Diese Präzisionslandwirtschaft, die hat vorne am Landwirtschaftsgerät traktorartiges Dingsbums, hat die vorne so lichtsensitiven Sensoren, die dann gucken, wie grün ist denn das Salatblatt unter mir. Und dann wird errechnet, wie viel Düngemittel von einem bestimmten Nährstoff genau diese eine Pflanze braucht. Und am hinteren Ende dieser Landmaschine fällt genau diese Menge auf genau diese Pflanze rauf. Und die Pflanze drei Meter weiter, kriegt was anderes oder gar nichts.
Selbst mit als Salattopf, der beregnet wird.
Genau, also da wird halt nur nach Schattierungen von Grün geguckt, was natürlich um ein unendliches einfacher ist, als ein menschliches Gesicht zu interpretieren und zu gucken, bist du blass, bist du nicht blass, hast du Augenringe, brauchst du mehr Spinat.
So, nachdem wir festgestellt haben, dass wir alle mehr Gemüse essen sollten, kommen wir jetzt mal zum politischen Teil. Und auch den würde ich grundsätzlich anfangen. Und zwar, das klang jetzt im Verlauf der Sendung möglicherweise schon an, dass biometrische Überwachung nicht die allergeilste Idee ist. Und zwar nicht nur deswegen, weil es nicht funktioniert. Aber, liebe Anwesende, ich möchte das noch mal ganz von vorne erklärt, das Versprechen, das mit der Überwachung des öffentlichen Raumes einhergeht, ist ja mehr Sicherheit. Wir können auch nachher noch gerne nochmal drüber reden, ob das wirklich funktionieren würde. Aber mal gesetzt, den Fall über eine biometrische Überwachung würde zu mehr Sicherheit führen. Was ist denn dagegen einzuwenden? Warum ist denn eine Überwachung gefährlich? Oder was ist die Kritik daran?
Die ist ausgesprochen vielfältig. Da kann ich als Ex Aussie sprechen. Ich hab DDR und Stasi ja noch persönlich miterlebt und kann bestätigen, wer ständig überwacht wird, fühlt sich nicht frei und ist auch nicht frei. Das ist schlicht so. Und wenn du die ganze Zeit weißt, dass irgendwelche unsichtbaren Kameras dich verfolgen, und heute ist das ja buchstäblich so, dass man theoretisch verfolgt werden kann, also in Großbritannien gibt es kaum noch öffentliche Plätze, wo dich keine Kameras angucken, dann verhältst du dich anders. Dann hast du letztendlich ein eingeschränktes Freiheitsrecht, du hast ein eingeschränktes Demonstrationsrecht, weil du dich nicht mehr anonym äußern kannst in deiner Meinung, was wir eigentliche in der Verfassung so drin stehen haben, weil du rein theoretisch jederzeit identifiziert werden könntest und möglicherweise Menschen von deinen politischen Überzeugungen oder spezifischen Überzeugungen erfahren, von denen du das nicht möchtest. Dann werden Dinge miteinander verbunden, die du nicht verbunden haben möchtest. Du wirst die ganze Zeit behandelt wie ein potenzieller Verbrecher. Also auch wenn jetzt die Personalausweise z.B. sämtliche Fingerabdrücke haben sollen, wir haben doch, glaube ich, alle tief in uns verwurzelt. Fingerabdrücke abnehmen ist was für Verbrecher. Das kennt man aus den Krimis, wo die so ihre Finger abrollen müssen. Das assoziiert man damit. Und wenn jetzt alle das machen müssen, ist das schon eine Behandlung von uns allen, als wären wir potenzielle Verbrecher. Und das gehört sich einfach nicht. Alle Leute, von denen, das hat ja Andrea so schön gesagt, die meisten, fast alle, völlig unschuldig sind und gar keine Verbrecher, die alle zu überwachen und in ihren Grundrechten einzuschränken, ist einfach eine Verletzung des Prinzips der Verhältnismäßigkeit.
Ich möchte an einer Stelle mal nachfragen, weil das nicht allen sofort klar ist, und zwar auf eine Demonstration gehen und anonym sein, wie das zusammengeht. Kannst du das nochmal erklären? Weil ein naiver Blick ist ja so, Moment mal, wenn ich auf einer Demonstration bin, das ist doch öffentlicher Raum, da kann doch jeder sehen, sowieso sehen, dass ich da bin.
Ja, aber ich trag doch nicht einen Personalausweis auf meinem Rücken oder ein Namensschildchen vorn. Also ich bin nicht ohne Weiteres erkennbar. Mit Maske schon mal gleich gar nicht. Aber inzwischen gibt es Gesichtserkennungen, die mit Maske hervorragend funktioniert und eine Erkennungsrate auch von über 80 Prozent hat. Das heißt, ich wäre bei einer normalen Demo für einen Durchschnittspolizisten nicht identifizierbar, für die Kamera schon.
Ich würde das ein bisschen anders beschreiben. Also ich stimme da schon zu, aber ich finde es besser verstehbar, wenn man sich anguckt, was macht denn der Datenschutz eigentlich? Es geht ja nicht darum, dass irgendwie der Bäcker meinen Namen ruft, sondern es geht darum, dass ich Gegenstand von Datenverarbeitung bin. Das heißt, dass ich irgendwo die Straße lang laufe, ist erstmal öffentlich, aber es ist nicht Gegenstand von Datenverarbeitung. Das heißt, ich bin da, aber ich bin sozusagen, die Frage anonymen heißt ja, für wen denn anonymen? Es gibt ja gar keinen Beobachter. Die Leute um mich herum sehen mich, aber die vergessen mich wieder und deren Kopf ist guter, die machen keine Datenverarbeitung. Aber in dem Moment, wo eine Kamera anfängt, etwas aufzunehmen, werden Sachen systematisiert, kategorisiert, sie werden abgespeichert, sie können weitergegeben werden. Auf einmal wird daraus ein Datum. Das heißt, da ändert sich die Qualität. Und wenn diese Kamera zu dem Teil des Staates gehört, die das Altmonopol inne hat, dann wird das noch problematischer. Dass ich auf einer Demo stehe, alleine, ist es völlig egal, ob ich mein Gesicht gerade in die strahlende Sonne halte. Das ist eine freiheitliche demokratische Welt hier. Natürlich kann ich das machen. Das ist ja nicht gleich eine Einwilligung, dass der Staatsapparat mich durchscannen kann. Das ist eben auch ein Teil, ich will mal das, was Anke eben beschrieben hat, von der anderen Seite der Medaille beschreiben, um meiner Meinung nach das Bild auch zu kompletieren. Ich bin nicht die Person, die hinten muss, warum ich nicht abgefilmt werden soll. Sondern ich bin die Person, die sich die Begründung anhören muss, warum ich abgefilmt werden sollte. Denn was du hier gerade sagst, ist, mal angenommen, es brächte uns mehr Sicherheit. Das ist so ein bisschen wie ein Gedankenexperiment. Angenommen, wir würden alle Parkbänke violett abnehmen, das brächte uns mehr Sicherheit. Das können wir gerne diskutieren, aber es ist ja nicht so. Ich möchte von denen, die das mögen, die das machen wollen, möchte ich hören, was genau die Folge davon ist. Und dann kann man die Folgen diskutieren. Und auch die Verhältnismäßigkeit und so weiter. Ich würde mich da ganz in die offensive stellen und sagen, was meinst du denn, was an Sicherheit besser wird? Es gibt ja keine Sicherheit, es gibt nur verschiedene andere Freiheitsrechte. Meine Freiheit, körperliche Unversehrtheit, meine Freiheit auf und so weiter, die werden dann vielleicht von Bösewichten irgendwie eingeschränkt. Aber diese Belege stehen doch hinten und vorne aus. Das ist ja so ein Punkt, den ich da ganz relevant finde. Also ich würde das nicht so defensiv machen.
Okay, eine kleine Ergänzung zu dem, was Rainer sagte. Klassische Videoüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum ist schon doof. Allerdings werden da riesige Datenmengen produziert. Das heißt, damit kann ich gar nicht so einfach dann auch wirklich alle permanent und überall überwachen. Aber wenn ich diese Videodaten biometrisch verarbeite, dann muss ich nur noch diese biometrischen Daten speichern. Und damit werden diese vormals riesigen Datenmengen plötzlich handhabbar. Das macht diese biometrische Überwachungstechnik in meinen Augen noch gefährlicher.
Ja, ich würde gerne noch anbringen, wie die Begründung, mit der der EUGH die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gekippt hatte. Nämlich aus zwei Gründen. Das eine war die Verhältnismäßigkeit. Wegen ganz weniger Verdächtiger werden ganz, ganz viele Unschuldige überwacht und in ihren Freiheitsrechten eingeschränkt. Und genau das Thema, was gerade eben schon beschrieben worden ist, dass die Evidenz nicht nachgewiesen worden ist. Dass man also immer wieder, wie Sascha Lubow das mal schön, esoterische Sicherheitspolitik genannt, auf einem Kongress und ich finde, das passt ganz gut. Und das zitiere ich auch immer wieder gern, weil es genau so ist, die Versprechen, symbolpolitische Sicherheit ohne einen einzigen Nachweis dafür zu erbringen. Und das Problem, wenn wir so eine flächendeckende Gesichtserkennung hätten, ist ja nicht nur, dass ich eine Person an einer Stelle auf dieser einen Demo identifizieren könnte. Ich kann ja auch Bewegungsprofile machen. Ich kann auch feststellen, aha, morgens war sie da, mittags war sie da, abends war sie da. Und ich kann feststellen, mit wem war die Person denn hier, da und da. Ich kann also auch Beziehungsprofile erstellen. Ich kann am Ende wirklich eine vollständige Profilierung einzelner Personen machen. Und dann stellt sich dann auch wieder die Forderung, eigentlich schon sehr, sehr viel früher, die das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch schon aufgestellt hat, nämlich, dass man eine Überwachungsgesamtrechnung braucht, dass man gar nicht nur jede einzelne Maßnahme beurteilen muss nach Nutzen und Verhältnismäßigkeit, also wie viel mehr Sicherheit und wie viele sind betroffen und wie viele nicht, sondern auch, dass man gucken muss, was gibt es denn drum herum noch für andere Maßnahmen und wie addieren die sich übereinander, dass man eben nicht diesen sogenannten Chilling-Effekt kriegt, wo eine Demokratie anfängt, nicht mehr eine Demokratie für freie Menschen zu sein, sondern diktatorische Züge zu kriegen, wo man einfach Menschen massenüberwacht?
Jetzt würde ich sagen, dann doch noch Fragen zu diesem Mehrsicherheit. Jetzt ist ja die Tatsache, Überwachung bringt mehr Sicherheit, kann ja zwei Dinge bedeuten. Das eine ist sozusagen, potenzielle Verbrecher fühlen sich durch die Überwachung abgeschreckt. Und die andere ist, das ist kein direkter Gewinn, weil sich erst mal niemand abgeschreckt wird. Aber wenn Verbrechen passieren, dann kann man die zuverlässiger aufklären, weil man weiß, wer es war. Gibt es zu diesen beiden Annahmen überhaupt schon wissenschaftliche, also außer der Vermutung, dass es so sein könnte, gibt es dazu irgendwelche Arbeiten oder Ergebnisse? Weiß man da was?
Also man weiß zumindest, dass der Staatstrojaner nicht erfolgreich eingesetzt worden ist in den letzten, weiß nicht, ein Jahr, zwei Jahre.
Den Staatstrojaner würde ich jetzt sozusagen nicht unter anlasslose Massenüberwachung...
Es ist eine Überwachungsmaßnahme, die den gleichen Charakter hat wie alle anderen, dass sie nie evaluiert und nie überprüft wird. Selbst wenn es in einem Gesetz drin steht, das wird dann einfach nicht gemacht.
Genau, also bei Videoüberwachung ist es ja glaube ich auch schon lange bekannt, dass das überhaupt keinerlei Straftaten verhindert. Dann käme es eher in die zweite Frage rein, was ist, wenn jetzt jemand gefunden wird, durch eine Videoüberwachung später, wo der Mord schon begangen ist, die Person schon verprügelt ist oder was auch immer. Ja, also würde ich auch nicht sagen, dass das dann wirklich, also das ist auch nicht wirklich hilfreich. Also bisher sind Verbrechen nicht minimiert worden durch diese Überwachungstechniken.
Und Aufklärungsquoten auch nicht in die Höhe gegangen.
Genau, auch nicht in die Höhe gegangen. Das ist immer nur das Versprechen. Und das zieht tatsächlich auch so einen Druck nach, sich eine Aufklärung zu erbringen. Also es gibt so eine schöne Geschichte aus 2017, wo in New York ein Ladendiebstahl mit Biometrie aufgeklärt wurde. Völlig absurd. Das AFIS, das automatisierte Fingerabdruckidentifikationssystem der New Yorker, das NYPD, hat niemand gefunden auf das Foto hin vom Tatort sozusagen. Das war so verpixelt. Und die Person, die da einen Diebstahl begangen hat, die war nicht zu erkennen. Dann hat die Polizei kreativ, wie sie war, gedacht. Also ein Polizist meinte, der sieht irgendwie Woody Harrelson ähnlich in so und so Filmen, Natural Born Killers oder wo auch immer. Dann haben die sich ein gut aufgelöstes Foto von Woody Harrelson, ein passendes, mit dem man gut eine Datenbank durchsuchen kann, bei Google gesucht und haben mit dem Foto von Woody Harrelson eine Kandidatenliste aus dem ARFIS rausgeholt und haben daraufhin tatsächlich jemanden festgenommen.
Aber funktioniert doch anscheinend.
Super.
Ein blindes Wumm findet auch mal einen Korn. Genau, aber das Interessante ist, da gibt es diesen schönen Podcast von MIT Technology Review, diesen in Machines We Trust. Da wird auch ein Polizist dazu interviewt und der kann überhaupt nichts Falsches daran erkennen. Also es ist halt so eine Zwangsläufigkeit. Wir haben doch jetzt die ganze Technik, wir müssen doch jetzt irgendwie hinfinden.
Oder wolltest du noch was sagen?
Nee, das nimmt dann auch so absurde Züge oft an. Und wo Anke DDR oder Sozialismus angesprochen hat, sind ja auch so Systeme gewesen, in denen es angeblich wegen des Sozialismus keine Kriminalität mehr geben durfte. Das durfte. Die gab es natürlich trotzdem. Häusliche Gewalt, wirklich Schwerverbrechen, das gab es natürlich alles. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ein Irrglaube, mit irgendeiner, also menschliche Gesellschaft, mit irgendeiner Form von Repression und Überwachung da hinzubringen, dass sie sicherer wird im Sinne von niemand tut mir jemand anderes irgendwas Böses an.
Aber wie ist das? Ich wollte nochmal da auch anschließen gerne, wenn das passt. Und zwar, ich finde diese Unterscheidung zwischen verhindern und im Nachhinein aufklären, ich finde die super wichtig, weil wenn da irgendwas verhindern, dann gleich über wesentliche Sachen gucken, nachdenken und sprechen. Aber die einzigen Sachen, die tatsächlich irgendwie Verbrechen verhindern, sind diese vorherige, was weiß ich, was auch immer man da als soziale Prävention von der Sozialarbeit, Überbildung und so weiter, kann man ja ewig groß, aber es ist eigentlich komplizierter, aber tatsächlich helfen. Das Quoten, das hat man auch in Berlin gesehen zu der Zeit, wo die BVG angefangen hat mit Videoüberwachung, die haben sich einfach auch nicht verändert. Das heißt, wenn da mal einer gefunden wird, den dann insbesondere die Konservativen gerne hochhalten und sagen, wenn auch nur ein Menschenleben gerettet würde, dann nützt es schon. Das sind die gleichen Leute, die dann gegen eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit aufauten. Aber gut, wenn nur eine Person gerettet würde, dann hat sich das schon gelohnt. So kann man natürlich nicht Politik machen und auch nicht irgendwie eine Gesellschaft strukturieren. Diese drei Fälle gibt es sicherlich, aber das ist überhaupt nicht relevant an der Stelle. Natürlich glaube ich, wir sind ja alle für mehr Sicherheit. Also im Sinne von uns passiert nichts, wenn wir da rumlaufen. Aber mich stört daran an der Diskussion, ich weiß nicht, warum die Verfechter das tatsächlich verfechten, weil sozusagen alle Evidenz weist in ganz andere Richtungen. Also was weiß ich, soziale Brennpunkte usw. Und wenn wir uns auch angucken, die Krimisraten zumindest in den Städten hier, sind überall sinkend. Also ich sehe auch nicht das Flammenmeer, was über die Welt hereinbricht, wenn wir nicht auf einmal alle öffentlichen Plätze überwachen. Ich sehe auch das Bedrohungsszenario an der Stelle gar nicht. Und an der anderen Seite sagen dann die Polizeikräfte selber, wir sind total understaffed, wir wissen nicht, was Tor ist. Deswegen rauschen wir bei Leuten rein, die so einen Server bei sich in der Wohnung stehen haben. Teilweise haben wir nicht genug Benzin für die Autos usw. Da denke ich mir so ein bisschen, wenn wir wahrhaftig über Sicherheit diskutieren, dann ist biometrische Videoüberwachung von öffentlichen Plätzen der letzte Punkt, den wir überhaupt durchdenken sollten. Ich verstehe diese ganze Diskussion dabei nicht. Und das ist natürlich, ja, vielleicht könnt ihr mir helfen.
Vielleicht kann Anke dazu noch was erzählen, weil sie hatte ja vorhin schon so eine kleine Anekdote aus der KI-Anket. Und wenn ihr euch mit dem Thema beschäftigt habt, werden da ja unter Umständen vermutlich auch BefürworterInnen gesessen haben. Was sind denn, also hast du da ein Gefühl für, oder vielleicht auch aus einer anderen Arbeit, aus den anderen Teilen deiner Arbeit im Bundestag, was die Idee dahinter ist? Also das müsste man, also selbst wenn man den Befürwortern das Bestmögliche unterstellt, müssen die ja mindestens zugeben, dass es so eine Art Rechtsgüterabwägung gibt. Und dann fällt mir aber sozusagen genau nur das Beispiel an, was Rainer gesagt hat, nämlich man sagt halt, ja nur ein Menschenleben, das muss dann halt irgendwie rechtfertigen, dass wir alle überwacht werden. Aber warum? Kannst du dazu was sagen?
Also ich glaube, bei den Innenpolitikern konservativer Parteien gibt es einerseits eine Überbetonung von Aspekten innerer Sicherheit, die mit mit Strafverfolgung zu tun haben, mehr als mit Prävention. Das ist ja eigentlich genau das Thema, was wir gerade auch hatten. Und weil es dieses Übergewicht der Strafverfolgung geht, also Leute bestrafen, wichtiger ist, als Opfer zu verhindern, deswegen setzt man auch jetzt zusätzlich besonders auf Technik, weil es sich, glaube ich, die sich das oft auch einreden. Ich glaube, manchmal glauben die das tatsächlich, dass man damit was bewirken kann. Und die haben vielleicht in dem von mir zitierten Beispiel nicht geglaubt, dass man überall nur eine 0, 1% Fehlerrate hat. Aber die haben sich gedacht, 80% sind ja auch gut. Dann sind halt 20% Fehler drauf geschissen. Hauptsache 80%. Aber was ich gerne noch erzählen würde, wir hatten ja auch diverse Anträge in dieser Legislatur, mal am Bundestag, wo es darum ging, dass es keinen Einsatz biometrischer Gesichtserkennung in öffentlichen Räumen geben soll. Das ist jetzt im Januar im Bundestag im Plenum debattiert worden. Da haben Grüne, Linke und FDP sich also ganz explizit gegen diese Gesichtserkennung ausgesprochen. SPD und Union waren da deutlich moderater. Also die SPD sagt dann, sie will auf jeden Fall mehr Debatte zum Thema haben. Die Union, die in den Kreisen, wo ich in der Enquete-Kommission drin war, immer alles ganz toll fand und schön viel Überwachung haben wollte, die haben zumindest da im Plenum erklärt, die wollen Rechtsfragen prüfen. Aber eine Partei, Überraschung, die AfD, die hat es halt ein wunderbares Verhandlungsinstrument gefunden. Und das bringt mich gleich zu einer potentiellen anderen Nebenwirkung, nämlich der Frage, was passiert denn mit einer flächendeckenden Überwachungsinfrastruktur, wenn bestimmte Personen oder politische Ausrichtungen, die unter ihrer Kontrolle kriegen. Und da ist mir relativ klar, warum die AfD solche feuchten Träume hatte, weil die einfach davon träumen, bestimmte Leute ausfindig zu machen und im Zweifelsfall schlimme Dinge mit denen zu tun, alle ins Gefängnis zu stecken, aufzuhängen oder was weiß ich. Da wird ja nicht viel Hehl draus gemacht. Und da wundert mich das nicht, weil die sind ja auch keine großen Verteidiger von Grundrechten. Die Grundrechte sind denen im Prinzip scheißegal. Also jetzt im Zusammenhang mit Corona-Demos finden sie bestimmte Grundrechte total wichtig, aber normalerweise nicht. Insofern ist es aus deren Sicht völlig nachvollziehbar. Tolles Fahndungsinstrument, was interessieren uns die Grundrechte. SPD und Union wägen zumindest ab. Grüne Linke und FDP sind allerdings ganz klar dagegen.
Und beim ganz klar dagegen sein kommen wir jetzt zum Anlass dieser Sendung, nämlich dieser Kampagne. Reclaim Your Face ist eine europäische Kampagne. Und auch hier eine einfache Frage, was genau wollen die eigentlich? Also letztlich sozusagen ihr, weil ihr alle sozusagen irgendwie mit drin hängt. Teilweise konkret auf der Webseite als Testimonial. Teilweise weil ihr sozusagen unterstützenden Organisationen angehört.
Genau, wir...
Was ist das Ziel?
Wir fordern ein Verbot biometrischer Massenüberwachung. Und zwar von der Europäischen Union. Konkret von der Europäischen Kommission. Weil das die sind, die auf EU-Ebene Gesetzentwürfe vorlegen können.
Das heißt sozusagen, die würden den Gesetzentwurf vorlesen, der würde dann beschlossen. Und wenn das so ist, würde der ein nationales Recht umgesetzt, dann hätte man das Problem EU-weit erschlagen. Gibt es, also hat diese Kampagne einen konkreten Gesetzesvorschlag? Wird der da mitgeliefert? Oder ist eher so die Sache so, Leute, ihr müsst euch da jetzt mal darum kümmern?
Letzteres, also es gibt keinen konkreten Vorschlag, sondern die Aufforderung ist relativ kurz gehalten. Wir fordern ein Verbot biometrischer Massenüberwachung, und dann wird das noch kurz begründet.
Jetzt wird im Rahmen dieser Kampagne werden 1 Mio. Unterschriften gesammelt. Sind das 1 Mio. Unterschriften, weil das eine schöne Zahl ist? Oder hängt da irgendeine technische Konsequenz dran?
Da hängt tatsächlich was dran, weil das nicht einfach nur so eine Online-Kampagne ist, wo man mal Unterschriften sammelt, sondern das ist eine europäische Bürgerinitiative. Das heißt, wenn wir diese 1 Mio. Unterschriften plus einen gewissen Puffer sammeln, dann muss die EU-Kommission sich mit unserem Thema befassen. Es gibt dann erst ein Treffen mit der EU-Kommission, dann gibt es eine öffentliche Anhörung im Europäischen Parlament. Danach muss ich wieder die Kommission öffentlich und schriftlich zu unserem Vorhaben äußern und auch erklären. da hängt rechtlich was dran. Das ist eine ordentliche Bürgerinneninitiative.
D.h. ist das vergleichbar mit den E-Petitionen vom Bundestag? Wenn man genug Unterschriften zusammen hat, dann muss sich der gesetzgebende Körper damit beschäftigen?
Genau, das ist was Vergleichbares auf EU-Ebene.
Und diese eine Million, die da gefordert wird, ist das viel? Oder ist das eher das... Ich hab von dem Instrument vorher noch nie gehört, aber das wird ja nicht für jetzt erfunden worden sein. Gibt es da Erfahrungen? Sind eine Millionen viel? Oder ist das eigentlich so ein Ding, wenn man nur genug Leute zusammenbringt, die kräftig trommeln, dann geht das schon?
Eine Million ist sehr viel, sag ich. Es geht nicht nur um eine Million, sondern in verschiedenen Ländern muss man auch noch bestimmte Quoten erreichen. In Deutschland zum Beispiel müssen etwa 70.000 Unterschriften zusammenkommen. Und das alleine sind schon mal mehr als für die E-Petition beim Bundestag notwendig.
Das heißt 7 Millionen?
Das muss auch eine Mindestanzahl Länder erreicht sein. Da weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht. Mindestens 7. Ich hab jetzt gedacht, irgendwas zwischen 5 und 10. 7 passt ja dann ganz genau. Es können auch nicht ein Land da groß mobilisieren und dann der ganzen EU so eine Debatte aufzwingen. Ungarn oder Polen könnte einem da als schlechtes Beispiel einfallen. Wobei, auch da gibt es eine Zivilgesellschaft, die sich wehrt gegen bestimmte Dinge. Es ist schon ein paar Mal erreicht worden, glaube ich. Mindestens einmal erinnere ich mich, als es um das Recht auf Zugang zu Wasser ging. Die haben relativ schnell, glaube ich, sogar die 1 Million geknackt. Aber es ist wirklich nicht einfach. Das ist schon eine hohe Hürde.
Wir sprechen heute hier nur mit deutschen VertreterInnen. Jetzt ist es eine EU-weite Kampagne. Wie findet die Zusammenarbeit statt?
Zu Beginn haben sich vor allem Organisationen zusammengetan, die gemeinsam über European Digital Rights organisiert sind. EDRI, das ist, man kann fast sagen, so eine Art Dachverband Europäischer Datenschutz- und Netzpolitik-Organisation. Und aus EDRI heraus wurde, ja, Reclame Your Face, dieses Bündnis aufgestellt. Und inzwischen sind wir über das EDRI-Netzwerk hinaus deutlich gewachsen.
Und heißt das aber so sagen, ihr macht für Deutschland die Arbeit und das ist in anderen Ländern auch so? Oder gibt es tatsächlich, und EDRI organisiert das einfach alles und managet das? Oder ist es tatsächlich so, dass da auch ein inter-europäischer Austausch in einem, keine Ahnung, wöchentlichen Big Blue Button Call stattfindet?
Ja, tatsächlich genauso, wobei wir uns alle zwei Wochen über Big Blue Button treffen. Zumindest mit den Organisationen, die im Kern dabei sind, die aktiver dabei sind. Und darüber hinaus gibt es eine Mailing-Liste, über die wir uns austauschen.
Und kannst du sagen oder könnt ihr sagen, wie viele Länder da jetzt mit am Start sind? Sind das alle oder gerade mal die sieben, die man braucht? Und wie ist die Begeisterung in anderen Ländern?
Und der Schwerpunkt liegt auf den sieben geforderten Ländern. Aber ich glaube, es sind inzwischen mehr als sieben.
Ich habe inzwischen schon acht gezählt. Ich hatte mal geguckt, wer so dabei ist. Also da ist aus Italien die Human Rights Group Hermes Center dabei, aus Griechenland Homo Digitalis, Bits of Freedom aus den Niederlanden, Juridikum Remedium aus Tschechien, Schere Foundation aus Serbien. Aus Deutschland gibt es weit über zehn verschiedene. Dann gibt es die Panoptikon Foundation aus Polen, La Quadratür du Net aus Frankreich. Das waren jetzt schon acht. Und ist möglicherweise ja nicht mal eine vollständige Liste.
Und die Unterschrift gibt man wie ab?
Derzeit noch online, entweder bei verschiedenen Partnerorganisationen oder zentral auf der Webseite reclaimyourface.eu. Ja, reclaimyourface.eu. Das heißt, da ist ja ein Feld, wo man ausnahmsweise, eben weil es eine europäische Bürgerinitiative ist, nicht nur Name und Mailadresse hinterlassen muss, sondern auch seine Postadresse in Deutschland ein. Und damit kann man dann online unterschreiben. Wir arbeiten aber auch daran, dass man über Papier was ausdrucken kann, das unterschreibt, und dann sammeln wir das irgendwie ein. Die Planung ist aber noch nicht ganz abgeschlossen.
Diese Kampagne oder diese Titel gibt es ja irgendwie seit Ende letzten Jahres. Aber jetzt ist Mitte Februar erst offiziell losgegangen, dieses mit den Unterschriften sammeln. In einem Jahr hat man da Zeit. Ich hab heute nachher noch einmal drauf geguckt, da waren es irgendwie so knapp 27.000, glaube ich. Das ist natürlich bis zu einem Million noch ein ganz schöner Schritt. Seid ihr zufrieden mit dem, wie es jetzt gerade geht? Also die Geschwindigkeit, mit der da Dinge schon angelaufen sind?
Ja und nein. Momentan sind wir über dem Schnitt, den wir pro Tag halten müssen. Also pro Schnitt mit ein bisschen Puffer landen wir bei knapp 3000 Unterschriften, die wir pro Tag sammeln müssen. Wir sind jetzt bei Tag 8. Allerdings gab es am Anfang so ein paar auch technische WW-Chien, die jetzt nach und nach aufgelöst werden und wurden.
Ich hab übrigens im Rahmen dieses Thema mit einer Forschung gesprochen von der FU Berlin. Die hatten mir was ganz Spannendes erzählt. Die haben geforscht zur Gesichtserkennung, zur Akzeptanz von Gesichtserkennung in verschiedenen Ländern. Die hat gesagt, in Deutschland ist es Genia Kostas heißt die üben. Kostka heißt die übrigens. Die hat erzählt, dass es in Deutschland ganz krass ist, weil im privaten Bereich wird Gesichtserkennung eher abgelehnt und im öffentlichen Bereich eher angenommen. Und das, obwohl die Menschen eigentlich wissen, dass Überwachung nicht so ganz gut ist. Sie vermutet so ein bisschen, dass da auch so eine Resignation stattfindet. Das ist ja eh Teil unseres Lebens, da können wir sowieso nichts machen. Das stelle ich mir aber für so eine Kampagne als ein ganz schwieriges Zielpublikum vor. Die also eh sagen, na ja, warum eigentlich nicht? Und dann außerdem eh so ein bisschen resigniert haben. Es gibt diese Website, es gibt ja auch, ihr macht Medienarbeit, diese Sendung findet gerade statt. Aber habt ihr da einen Plan, oder ist das einfach reinpowern und hoffen, dass man bei den Leuten ankommt? Oder vielleicht reichen ja die, die von der guten Sache TM überzeugt sind?
Also ich glaube, das reicht nicht. Momentan beschränken sich die unterstützenden Organisationen fast noch auf die übliche, ich sag mal Datenschutzbubble. Aber wir arbeiten gerade daran, genau diese Datenschutzbubble zu verlassen und eben auch Organisationen einzubinden, die das Thema auch betrifft. Zum Beispiel Organisation Die Geflüchtete unterstützen. Weil eben auch an Grenzen biometrische Überwachung stattfindet.
Ich habe noch einen weiteren Kommentar. Also müssen wir genau gucken, woher dieser Eindruck Leute da irgendwie, vielleicht sind sie tatsächlich, wie du gesagt hast, ich weiß nicht, entmutigt. Man kann aber auch genau so sagen, jetzt passiert da mal was. Und man muss glaube ich auch, ich finde es total wichtig, es ist ja nicht so, dass hier irgendwie ein paar Leute sich zusammengefrimmelt haben und die einfach eine Meinung haben. Auch der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte selbst hat verlautbaren lassen, es war im Oktober 2019, facial recognition, a solution in search of a problem. Also er hat sich auch ausgesprochen, als sozusagen EU-Institution, da mal ein Memorandum zu machen. Also es war jetzt so halberfolgreich. Aber ich will auch damit nur sagen, das hat schon auch sozusagen, auch auf dieser ist es jetzt nicht einfach nur irgendwie, ich antwurche, eine NGO-Forderung, sondern es ist auch sehr gut begründet, warum das eine gute Idee ist. Das sind jetzt auch nicht so wie spinnarte Leute oder so. Wie man natürlich mehr Leute dafür noch kriegen kann, das wird man sehen. Aber ich würde sagen, das hat auf alle Fälle was damit zu tun, das gut zu begründen und auch einfach eine Option aufzumachen. Man kann halt eh nichts tun, die Leute geben auf oder so, sondern zu sagen, natürlich, wir sind halt eine Demokratie und ihr hängt davon ab, dass Leute sich äußern. Das ist das, was jetzt gerade überall ausgerollt wird im schlechtesten Falle. Natürlich kann man das aufhalten.
Ich glaube, es gibt jetzt sogar so ein Möglichkeitenfenster, gerade in Bezug auf die Europäische Union. Die Europäische Kommission schreibt ja gerade an so einem White Paper zu künstlicher Intelligenz. Und da war bereits von Seiten der Europäischen Kommission gesagt worden, dass sie sehr hart darüber nachdenken, ein Moratorium für Gesichtserkennung an öffentlichen Orten zu verhängen innerhalb Europas. Was ja bedeutet, dass bestimmte Länder, die das schon ganz viel haben und das wieder rückgängig machen müssten, weil sie auch sehen, dass es da irgendwelche Probleme gibt. Das ist in der aktuellen Version nicht mehr drin. Aber immerhin waren sie ja so weit, schon mal laut drüber nachzudenken. Und es gibt gerade diverse Städte in den USA, wie San Francisco oder Boston oder Cambridge, wo die zumindest auf der Stadtebene entschieden haben, dass sie Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum nicht mehr einsetzen, aus bestimmten Gründen solche Überwachungstechnologien ablehnen. Und selbst große Firmen wie IBM, Microsoft oder Amazon haben angekündigt, Gesichtserkennungstechnik nicht mehr an Polizei zu verkaufen. Oder so lange nicht anzubieten, Microsoft hat das so formuliert, wie es keine Gesetzesgrundlage gibt, die garantiert, dass Menschenrechte eingehalten werden. Das heißt, selbst die Firmen kommen, IBM hat sogar den Verkauf komplett eingestellt und hat gesagt, sie wollen diese Technik, dass sie nicht für Massenüberwachung genutzt wird. Und da gibt es, glaube ich, eine Möglichkeit. Und wenn man jetzt in Deutschland noch bedenkt, dass wir vor einer Bundestagswahl stehen, wo die Sensibilität für Massenaktionen, für den Wunsch herauszufinden, wie tickt denn das Wahlvolk relativ hoch ist, da würde ich mal sagen, ist das kein schlechter Zeitpunkt.
Ich fand ganz kurz, in diesem Zusammenhang fand ich Matthias Aktion auch super spannend, sich wegen Clearview AI ein bisschen zu kümmern. Also das würde ich mir jetzt auch nochmal wünschen, dass wir kurz darüber reden, weil ich glaube auch, soweit ich das verstanden habe, ist ja die Poerte auch so ein bisschen, dass der Datenschutzbeauftragte, der dir da geholfen hat, Matthias...
Stopp, stopp, stopp, jetzt musst du die Geschichte von vorne erzählen.
Ja genau, jetzt soll Matthias sie erzählen, weil sie ist wirklich sehr schön.
Ja, dann erzähle ich jetzt die Geschichte von Clearview AI. Das ist eine Gesichtersuchmaschine mit Sitz in New York City. Und die haben mal eben drei Milliarden Bilder im Internet analysiert und die Gesichter da biometrisch verarbeitet. Das Ganze hat die New York Times vor 13 Monaten ungefähr veröffentlicht. Und weil es Bilder von mir im Internet gibt, habe ich diese Gesichtersuchmaschine mal nach meinen personenbezogenen Daten gefragt. Und ja, einen Monat später hat die Suchmaschine tatsächlich geantwortet und hat mir gezeigt, wo sie mein Gesicht schon im Internet gefunden hat. Das fand ich dann nicht in Ordnung, weil die Firma offensichtlich meine biometrischen Daten ohne meine Zustimmung verarbeitet hat. Und daraufhin habe ich mich beim Hamburgischen Datenschutzbeauftragten beschwert. Dann gab es ein wenig Hin und Her, ob jetzt die Datenschutzgrundverordnung anwendbar sei oder nicht. Wir kamen zu dem Schluss, dass die Datenschutzgrundverordnung angewendet werden kann, weil diese Suchmaschine unter anderem das Verhalten europäischer Bürgerinnen und Bürger beobachtet, dadurch, dass sie ebenso umfassend Bilder im Internet sucht und verarbeitet. Und vor wenigen Wochen, knapp einem Monat, hat der Hamburgische Datenschutzbeauftragte dann entschieden, dass das, was Clearview AI dort macht, nicht in Ordnung ist. Allerdings wurde nur angeordnet, dass diese Suchmaschine das zu meiner Person gehörende biometrische Datum löschen muss. Das heißt, die Suchmaschine hat noch mein Bild und die biometrischen Daten aller anderen Europäerinnen und Europäer stecken auch noch in dieser Suchmaschine. Insofern denke ich, dass wir da etwas tun müssen. Es wurde festgestellt, das, was die Suchmaschine tut, das ist nicht so ganz legal. Aber wir helfen jetzt nur mal dieser einen Person, die sich beschwert hat, und bei den anderen tun wir nichts. Das kann es aus meiner Sicht noch nicht sein.
Das Interessante an der Sache ist ja, dass du im Prinzip erst diesen hamburgischen Datenschutz, Kaspar, wie heißt er? Du hast den erst draufgebracht, die DSGVO auch mal sinnvoll anzuwenden. Das ist jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert, aber die Waffen sind ja da. Die DSGVO bietet ziemlich viel Handlungsspielraum. Sie wird aber nicht so richtig verwendet, um gegen Gesichtserkennung ins Feld zu ziehen. Das ist insgesamt so ein Problem mit der DSGVO. Da wird noch nicht so richtig rundeum mitgeschlagen. Da geht einiges. Das finde ich eine ziemlich schöne Poernte bei der Geschichte. Übrigens interessiert mich in dem Zusammenhang, hast du denn von Clearview AI die ganze Kandidatenliste bekommen? Also alle, die auf deinem Foto gematcht haben oder nur deins dann auch?
Das war sehr interessant. Ich habe einmal nach meinen Daten gefragt und dann haben sie mir wirklich nur meine Gesichter geliefert, zwei Stück. Ein Vierteljahr später, zwischendurch haben sie gesagt, meine Daten wurden jetzt gelöscht, mein Suchbild. Und ein Vierteljahr später haben sie dann trotzdem ungefragt noch einmal Auskunft erteilt. Und dieses Mal war ich zweimal zu sehen und dann waren dann noch acht andere Personen auf meinem Suchauszug.
Das waren also neue Bilder?
Genau.
Du hast dann aber konsequenterweise alle löschen lassen, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich habe jetzt nochmal nach meinen Daten gefragt.
Warte mal, das waren Bilder, da warst du drauf, aber auch andere Menschen? Oder du hast sozusagen Bilder bekommen, wo du nicht drauf warst, aber Leute, für die das System dich gehalten hat?
Sowohl als auch. Also die zwei Bilder, die gefunden wurden, die zeigen wirklich mich.
Warst du mal in einem Supermarkt? Mir fällt bei der Gelegenheit aber auch noch eine ganz lustige Geschichte ein, und zwar ist es eine Recherche, die Netzpolitik gemacht hat. Die haben nämlich eine Firma ausgegraben, die so etwas Ähnliches macht, aber einen Sitz im Polen hat, also mitten in der Europäischen Union. Die heißen PIM-Eis, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Die haben sich gedacht, wollen wir doch mal ein paar Abgeordnete anspitzen, und wie funktioniert es am besten, indem die betroffen sind. Also haben sie gedacht, nehmen wir doch mal zum Beispiel Anke, ich war nicht die einzige, aber haben da so mal irgendein öffentliches Foto von mir da hochgeladen. Und da spuckt einem dann diese Software oder dieser Dienst, spuckt einem dann alle möglichen Bilder aus, die ich sein soll, von egal wo im Internet. Und da gibt es ja auch ein paar. Und es hat 50, 60 Fotos gefunden. Ich kannte einige davon überraschenderweise überhaupt nicht. Und es waren wirklich, sagen wir mal, so 90% war ich. Vielleicht sogar noch ein paar Prozent mehr. Es waren ganz wenige, die dann aber auch völlig anders aussahen, wo ich mich noch gefragt hab, hä? Aber das meiste war ich. Und in manchen Sachen, ich weiß noch eins war, da saß ich als Publikum bei irgendeiner Talkshow im superdunklen, kaum zu erkennen, ganz winzig, nur eine ganz kleine, halbdunkle Gesichtsformation. Und das hat mich trotzdem da erkannt. Das war sehr weird. Es waren teilweise 10, 15 Jahre alte Fotos. Und da ich mich natürlich auch tierisch aufgeregt hab, ihr habt sie wohl nicht alle, darf nicht sein, und hab mich bei der brandenburgischen Datenschutzbeauftragten, weil die Länderebene von da, wo ich wohne, es zuständig beschwert, hab aber gedacht, schade auch nichts, wenn man dem Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten Ulrich Kelber darüber in Kenntnis setzt, habt auch einen schönen Brief hingeschrieben. Beide haben auch geantwortet. Also beide waren der Meinung, es ist ein Fall für die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, und zwar schon mal deshalb, weil das Unternehmen sich in Europa befindet und weil ich als Europäerin betroffen bin. Aber weil es ein europäisches Unternehmen ist, ist der polnische Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte, also von ganz Polen dafür zuständig. Und an den wurde das Verfahren von der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten in Brandenburg übergeben. Der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hat aber auch einen Brief hingeschrieben und hat gesagt, dass er dieses Verfahren quasi überwacht aus der Ferne und sich da Bericht erstatten lässt von den Polen. Und nachdem die Polen dieses polnische Unternehmen früher auf der Webseite noch angepriesen haben, dass man da zum Beispiel Fotos von der Ex oder Privatfotos von Celebrities finden kann, die die vielleicht gar nicht öffentlich haben wollen, das haben sie alles dann ganz schnell weggelöscht. Und sie haben dann in den nächsten Wochen auch ihren Firmen-Sitz vom Polen weg verlegt auf irgendeiner einsamen, weit weg Briefkastenfirmen-Insel. Und wie das jetzt weitergeht, weiß ich nicht. Aber es ist meines Wissens noch ein anhängiges Verfahren. Also das ist noch nicht vorbei. Und mit ein bisschen Glück müssen die wenigstens ordentlich zahlen.
Ich habe mich da auch beschwert. Für das Verfahren könnte es ganz interessant sein, ob die Firma noch ihre Büros und ihre Niederlassung in Wrocław, in Polen nutzt. Also wenn da jemand zuhört, der da zufällig vorbeikommt, ich würde mich über ein Foto fragen.
Das Schöne ist ja, dass die DSGVO auf alle zutrifft, die in Europa die Services anbieten. Egal wo sie sitzen, wie man dann da hinkommt. Das ist natürlich eine andere Frage. Aber ich finde das ist ein total gutes Beispiel, wo ich mich auch manchmal frage, warum müssen die Datenschutzbehörden da eigentlich zum Jagen getragen werden? Also offensichtlich sind sie auch einfach nicht ausgestattet.
Aber meine haben das beide gerne gemacht. Die können sowas nicht so ohne weiteres agieren und haben sich gefreut von mir, diesen Brief zu kriegen. Also alle beide, Bundesebene und Brandenburger Ebene, sind sofort losmarschiert.
Genau, doch, aber gerade die PIM-Eis, das ging doch durch die Medien rauf und runter. Wenn das mein Job ist, warum, also weiß ich nicht. Oder auch Johannes Kaspar, den Andrea von meinte in Hamburg, ich weiß auch nicht, warum da nicht aktiv... Also gerade an solchen symbolischen Punkten, das ist ja auch Vertrauensaufbau gegenüber den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern. Wenn die Datenschutzbehörden nicht nur rumhängen und sagen, Facebook ist ja ganz schön schlimm, sondern mal sagen...
Also jetzt, das ist nicht so, dass sie... Also man kann über die politische Arbeit des Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten, der Länderdatenschutzbeauftragten sicherlich reden, aber dass die den ganzen Tag einfach nur rumhängen, das halte ich doch für eine etwas arge Überspitzung.
Das stimmt natürlich. Ja, ja, da hast du schon völlig recht. Aber wir reden gerade davon, dass wir in Europa eine Welle von KI, von US-amerikanischen monopolistischen Riesenfirmen haben, mit biometrischer Videoüberwachung, hinten autonomes Fahren, vorne rum irgendwie. Also ich sehe schon, dass da was passiert. Aber wenn wir das Konzept einer Digitalisierung ernst nehmen, dann müssen wir doch vielleicht zumindest die Datenschutzbeauftragten in gleichem Maße wachsen lassen, wie wir die Geheimdienste wachsen lassen. Genau diese Bissigkeit. Ich wollte das jetzt gar nicht vorwerfen im Sinne von, sondern die sind ja auch hinten und vorne überlastet. Aber das meine ich halt damit. Wir reden alle seit 30 Jahren von der Informationsgesellschaft. Aber dann brauchen wir doch eben auch so eine bissigen Leute und dürfen nicht ständig auf Max Schrems warten. Also so meine ich das.
Es gibt jetzt diese Kampagne, zu der ich gerne zurückkehren möchte. Zu der hätte ich noch zwei Fragen. Die eine ist tatsächlich noch mal zu den Protagonisten. Es gibt ja diese Länder, es gibt EU-weit, jedes Land macht das dann dort. In Deutschland ist die Seite dann gesichtserkennung-stoppen.de und da gibt es dann sehr bekannte Testimonials. Ein gewisser Rainer Rehak ist auf der Seite zum Beispiel zu sehen. Oder eben auch der gerade benannte Ulrich Kälber, Konstanze Kurz, Markus Bekedahl, eine gewisse Anke Domscheit-Berg. Wenn man sich die Liste anguckt, sind das schon typische Player der deutschen Netzpolitik slash AktivistInnen-Bubble. Aber die Initiatoren der Deutschen Netz-Live ist ein Verein, der heißt Digitale Freiheit. Der war mir bis neulich noch überhaupt nicht über den Weg gelaufen. Und über den weiß ich auch, oder kann man auch nicht schnell viel rausfinden. Und das Vertrauen, dass das sozusagen vertrauenswerte Leute sind, kommt unter anderem daher, dass sie halt dieses Projekt anscheinend initiiert haben und dort sehr viele Leute mitmachen, die wiederum dann einen guten Leum und haben. Wer ist denn das eigentlich?
Also das ist ne Aktivistinnengruppe, die ist so plus minus an der TU Berlin angesiedelt. Und die sind so ein bunter Haufen, jetzt nicht riesengroß. Aber die hatten an dem Punkt, also ich kenn die auch so ein bisschen, schon ein bisschen länger, die fanden einfach Zeit, da gibt's ein Problem. Und offensichtlich gibt's da sozusagen niemanden, der da so ein bisschen die Fäden zusammenführt. Und die haben dann ihr Netz jeweils genutzt, um mit den entsprechenden Leuten zu sprechen. Und mit je mehr coolen Leuten man spricht, umso mehr andere coole Leute, sag ich jetzt mal, haben dann auch Lust, was dazu zu sagen. Und die gibt's auch schon, also ich hab die auch kennengelernt, 2017, da waren sie bei der Festtafel der Freiheit irgendwie auch dabei und haben da so einen Wagen gemacht mit Musik für Datenschutz und so. Also die sind so eine bunte Runde von Leuten, die finden, dass da mal was passieren muss. Und ab und zu machen sie halt so eine Art von, das war dann einfach so ein Projekt, was sie so angegangen sind.
Und die letzte Frage, die ich noch hätte, ist, was ich, und das ist vielleicht nur mein eigener Eindruck, das wirkt ja auf den ersten Blick wie so eine klassische NetzaktivistInnenaktion. Aber ich finde, es gibt was, was ist ein bisschen anders, weil es ging halt gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, da ging es sozusagen gegen ein konkretes Gesetz, ging gegen den Staatstrojaner, ging es auch klar gegen was Konkretes, gegen den Uploadfilter, gegen Netzwerken. Das waren alles so Themen, die hatten einen ganz konkreten, sehr eng fokussierten Angriffspunkt. Und ich finde, das ist hier ein bisschen anders, weil das ist ja eine Kampagne für etwas, also klar gegen Biometrieüberwachung, aber halt eben dafür zu sagen, hey Leute, es gibt hier ein Problemfeld, das ihr mal bearbeiten müsst. Jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, ist das wirklich so, oder ist das sozusagen nur was sehr Subtiles, was eigentlich keine Rolle spielt, und das ist eigentlich wie immer was ganz Klassisches, der Überwachungsstaat schafft Dinge, und dagegen muss man vorgehen. Macht das für euch, hat das für euch in der Arbeit irgendwie einen Unterschied gemacht, ist das eine neue Qualität, dass man jetzt quasi schon so ein bisschen vorneweg ist, auch klar, wenn es um eine Entwicklung geht, oder ist es genau dasselbe wie immer?
Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass das nicht passiert. Also die Ankündigung, dass auf allen Flughäfen und großen Bahnhöfen Deutschland solche Kameraüberwachung installiert werden soll, die hat es ja gegeben. Dass es am Ende dann doch nicht in ein Gesetz gemündet ist, haben wir in dem Fall vermutlich der SPD zu verdanken, aber es war ja kurz davor. Also wir haben das ja, das ist wie mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, auch die Kameraüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum kommt wie so ein untoter Zombie immer wieder. Das heißt, jeder Zeitpunkt ist der richtige. Und ich muss eigentlich gar nicht warten darauf, dass wieder ein neues Gesetz in der Schublade ist, weil ich mir sowieso sicher sein kann, dass da eins in der Schublade ist. Und dann kann man, ich hab ja vorhin versucht zu beschreiben, jetzt ist eigentlich ein ganz geschickter Zeitpunkt. Und vielleicht ist es auch ganz gut, dass es noch in einer Schublade liegt und gerade nicht auf dem Tisch liegt, weil man es dann vielleicht verhindern kann. Und da wäre jetzt wirklich ein geschickter Moment, einerseits ein Moratorium auszuhandeln und eben noch besser ein Verbot zu erreichen gegen Massenüberwachung durch Gesichtserkennung.
Vielleicht mal kurz zu sagen, Moratorium heißt ein zeitlich eingeschränktes Verbot. Also nicht für immer, sondern 3 oder 5 Jahre sind, glaube ich, in der Spur.
Ja, erstmal, um überhaupt die Sache besser zu verstehen und näher zu untersuchen. Da hätte unser eins natürlich die Hoffnung, dass die Untersuchung dann ergeben hat, dass es weiterhin gar keinen Sinn macht. Aber das, was ja alle, also selbst konservativere Lager, eine bestimmte braune Partei schließlich da aus, sich einig sind, ist, dass sie sagen, wir wissen eigentlich noch viel zu wenig. Und da könnte man über diesen Hebel vielleicht als erstes Moratorium hinkriegen. Das Ziel sollte aber unbedingt sein, deswegen sollte man auch immer dieses Ziel kommunizieren, dass es ein Verbot staatlicher Massenüberwachung durch Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum gibt.
Okay, aber von der politischen Arbeit ist es dasselbe wie immer?
Für mich eigentlich schon, ja.
Es ist, ja, naja, also es ist natürlich ein, also, dass man früher dran ist, wie eigentlich schon immer, dass man sagt, kann man so Entwicklungen verhindern, aber es ist natürlich auch ein weniger klares Ziel, was manchmal vielleicht in der Kommunikation dann ein bisschen, man muss sich eher auf breitere Grundwerte beziehen, als zu sagen, das ist ein Gesetz, was wir verhindern müssen. In dem Sinne gibt es so minimale, würde ich schon sagen, in der tatsächlichen Überzeugungsarbeit. Also man muss so ein bisschen das Ziel klarer definieren, bisschen wertebasierter argumentieren, so in diese Richtung.
Aber es gibt ja auch Anwendungsfälle in Europa. Und das ist ja eine europäische Initiative. Und da fand ich ganz spannend, wer auf diese Seite mal raufgeht. Der kann sich ja auch angucken. Da gibt es immer so kleine Berichte zu irgendwas. Da wird dann erzählt, eine bestimmte Stadt in Polen hat sich auch entschieden, keine Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum mehr zu haben. In Frankreich wollten sie Gesichtserkennung an Schulen haben und mussten das wegen einer Aktion von Reclaim Your Face-Unterstützern wieder einstellen. Das sind ganz konkrete Beispiele, die irgendwo in Europa gerade stattfinden. Und die man sich dann als Anlass in der jeweiligen Region, im jeweiligen Land, rauspickt. Und diese eine Klammer über alles rüberlegt, was dann Gesichtserkennung in der Schule verbindet mit der Gesichtserkennung auf öffentlichen Bahnhöfen und vielleicht auch irgendwo an Supermärkten. Und dann eine gemeinsame Geschichte daraus macht anhand vieler verschiedener Beispiele. Also viele Puzzle, ein Gesamtbild.
Dann würde ich an dieser Stelle, glaube ich, zum Abschluss kommen wollen. Denn ich denke, wir haben genau das geschafft, was ich am Anfang versucht habe zu versprechen. Nämlich ein solides Basiswissen zum Thema Biometrie und Überwachung an öffentlichen Plätzen oder im öffentlichen Raum. Und dazu Hilfe von neuen Technologien zu machen. Vielen Dank euch, dass ihr alle hier wart. Hat noch jemand ein Famous Last Word? Ich kann das Gespräch gerne die Runde noch mal durchgeben. Rainer, möchtest du noch etwas zum Abschluss mitgeben? Den Menschen, die zuhören an den neuartigen Rundfunk-Ampfangsgeräten?
Ja, ich würde vielleicht noch sagen, dass dieses Verbannen oder dieses Stoppen der Videoüberwachung, das ist ja auch eine bestimmte Art von Technologie, die man braucht, um diese Plätze zu überwachen. Dass man immer auch mit denken muss, wenn das in Europa möglich ist, dann wird es auch hier eine Industrie geben, die genau diese Sachen herstellt. Und diese Industrie wird sich nicht nur mit einem EU-internen Geschäftsfeld zufrieden geben. D.h. da gibt es noch eine andere Sache, das kann man jetzt noch machen. Aber der Kram wird dann natürlich auch exportiert werden, rund um die Welt. Und das ist natürlich, ich finde, das ist auch ein Punkt, der mir sagen würde, es ist noch weiterer Grund, da einfach nicht in diese Richtung da einfach mitzumachen bei so einer Entwicklung.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, ich finde die Initiative Reclaim Your Face super. Ich hoffe auch, dass sie die Bubble verlässt. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, dass man gegen massenhafte Gesichtserkennung eigentlich nichts mehr tun kann. Und genau deswegen muss man was dagegen tun. Deswegen muss sie verboten werden.
Ja, da kann ich direkt anschließen. Ich habe nämlich Vorschläge, was man tun kann. Die haben natürlich mit meinem direkten Umfeld zu tun. Schreibt an Abgeordnete und zwar an zwei Typen von Abgeordneten. Schreibt an die, in deren Wahlkreis ihr wohnt, weil die interessieren sich für euch, die anderen nicht so sehr. Und schreibt an die, die Mitglied im Innenausschuss sind. Und zwar egal, in welchem Wahlkreis die aktiv sind. Und dann diese gleichen, denen könnt ihr entweder Briefe schreiben, ihr könnt auch die Büros anrufen, da erreicht man immer irgendjemand, könnt ihnen ein Öhrchen abkauen. Ihr könnt aber, und das ist fast noch besser, ihr könnt auch beides machen, diese MdBs über Abgeordneten-Watch anfragen. Keine Massenanfragen, die werden von Abgeordneten-Watch abgebogen, aber zum Beispiel die in eurem Wahlkreis. Die könnt ihr einfach konkret fragen, was ist eure Position zur Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum? Und natürlich schreibt ihr noch einen Dreizeiler dazu, warum ihr glaubt, dass es eine ganz schlechte Idee wäre, das zu machen. Und ihr könnt auch hingehen, wenn es jetzt im Demnächst ganz viele verschiedene Wahlveranstaltungen digital oder analog gibt, und fragt die einfach. Dann zwingt ihr nämlich auch die, die sich sonst mit Ferkelkastration beschäftigen, über dieses Thema nachzudenken und könnt auf diese Weise Aufklärung machen. Was dann nämlich passiert, wenn ich kriege zum Beispiel Briefe zu Ferkelkastration, ich komme immer wieder auf dieses sehr schöne Beispiel, ich frage dann unsere agrarpolitische Sprecherin und sage, oh, keine Ahnung, von Ferkel erzähl mal und dann schickt die mir da so ein Traktat und schon weiß ich ein bisschen besser als vorher Bescheid über diese Ferkelchen. Genau so würde das passieren, wenn ihr alle Briefe schreibt an diese Abgeordneten und denen erklärt, warum sie jetzt auch gegen diese Überwachung sein sollen. Und dann müssen die sich mit dem Thema beschäftigen. Ihr könnt ja auch reinschreiben, hört doch doch dieses Chaosradio an. Seitdem ihr das gehört habt, seid ihr total überzeugt davon. Schlechte Idee. Wenn die das anhören, sind sie bestimmt auch davon überzeugt. Vielleicht hört es ja dann mal einer von denen an.
Markus, du musst jetzt dieses Chaosradio selber in unsere Show Notes tun.
Okay, Chaosradioception. Und den Abschluss dieser Chaosradioception macht Matthias. Möchtest du auch noch ein letztes Wort an die Allgemeinheit richten?
Gerne. Also ich finde das natürlich auch sehr schön, wenn ihr eure VolksvertreterInnen anschreibt. Ihr könnt aber auch Firmen oder staatliche Behörden anschreiben und fragen, welche Daten sie über euch haben oder fragen, wie sie in der Öffentlichkeit überwachen, um dann Transparenz und eine gewisse Öffentlichkeit herzustellen.
So, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr habt was gelernt und ihr habt Hausaufgaben mitbekommen. Dabei wünsche ich viel Spaß. Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart. Vielen Dank Rainer, Andrea, Anke, Matthias, dass ihr dabei wart und uns Zeit und Erklärungen hier gelassen habt. Danke dafür nochmal. Und ich verabschiede mich an dieser Stelle und mir bleibt am Ende der Sendung nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht biometrisch überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.